[Music]
so
hello
and welcome back
um it's been a nice little break for us
and we're now going to be back with
another match and probably the match i'm
most eagerly anticipating it's the match
between russia
and hungary
and i say i'm eagerly anticipating
because russia are one of the main
favorites and they've got so many
superstars i'm not saying hungry don't
but russia really had the top elite
players and it's always a joy to see the
likes of nepo play and you know all the
others duboff this very imaginative and
talented player so we're gonna um get to
those games very shortly we give you an
update on
the proceedings of india versus armenia
when we get a chance but let's let's
just move on to some positivity shall we
now you thank you let's see some good
chess let's let's have a look at the
chess i'm really excited to see what
they have come up with
so the first game is uh of course
yeah so edos this one i'm excited about
because victor erdos has a reputation of
being an incredibly solid player
he is he's a very solid player but
nepo's nepo i mean nepo is sort of
leading the candidates at the moment one
of the strongest players in the world
and a future world champion a lot of
people have said so it's going to be a
really tough match for hungary there's
no doubt about that at all they're up
against it anyone who plays russia is up
against it uh having black against nepo
oh i i would be slightly slightly scared
so we have a bishop b4 check sicilian
and after pawn takes d4 queen takes
a6
bishop has captured on d7 and this is a
fairly standard line
where white gains a space advantage in
the center of the board
but black gains the two bishops and is
quite solid
now queen takes is a bit of a peculiar
move it looks much more natural to bring
the bishop out so
my theory on this move is not not so not
so good
so that's already a surprise for me
ivanka that move queen takes d7 mm-hmm
yeah i know i i think i've seen bishop
takes d7 and i've even seen white castle
on some occasions castle queen side
sorry yeah black can often do this but
queen takes just looks really weird um
because you're not developing your piece
you're putting your queen on a weird
square the only logical thing i think is
that the bishop wants kind of b7 but
one of the dangers with this kind of
setup that black has and the open
sicilian sicilian in general black
positionally can claim to be better
because more central pawns but black
often gets a long way behind in
development
and this is not helping that cause must
be theory we will come back to it ivanka
let's go through the board shall we
yep let's have a look at dubov uh this
is uh benjamin gledura against daniel
dubov
so
benjamin glendora is quite a young
player a very talented player but duboff
i think it's fair to say one of the most
creative talents around
at this moment in time in the world he
comes up some great ideas doesn't leave
anchor i'm just going to blast through
the blues
yeah i like this kind of philosophy in
life that you know
no one was playing in a style that he
particularly liked so could emulate so
he decided fine just gonna just kind of
create my own style myself so i kind of
like that that's originality
he's a very unique character g buff and
he does come up with some of the best
opening ideas this is why he worked for
magnus carlsen as his second during the
world championships and stuff in in
previous occasions but surely he's a
contender himself to be world champion
and it is nice yeah if you don't like
anyone else's style you create your own
bit like bruce lee is he the bruce lee
of chess then juboff
little bruce lee of chess
so they have um a catalog where jupoff's
grabbed the pawn on c4
so he's going
reasonably sharp line and b5 holds on to
that pawn but you're opening up the
bishop on g2
now
b3 is the sacrifice we've seen if you
were with our commentary yesterday quite
a common idea
point being
you get a lot of play on these files
c6
rook to f1 here comes that pressure
positional pressure bishop b7 and now
queen b2 i guess to step out the way of
any a4 moves
and white's
white's idea the compensation now is
that he's defending d4 as well and he
can go knight e5 he has these nice
squares ivanka kind of a typical pawn
sack
yeah it's a very standard spawn sack you
get a lot of harmony for your for your
pawn and like you say i love this uh
knight e5 idea they're obviously not now
because you you don't want to be
occupying the square of the pawn
um and i also quite like the c5 square
and this bishop on b7 doesn't make a
great impression
and okay yeah i like this idea of knight
e1 just to go knight d3 uh pleduro is of
course a positional player
he's uh you know he likes his catalans
and his positional pressure i do
remember that he actually defeated um
vichy anand in gibraltar actually in one
year that we were comment commentating
so glidura is capable of a lot of upsets
yeah he is i mean he's he's he's a great
player and he's i mean still quite young
and improving
this kind of position
i think we'll i don't know i'm just
going to say suit him more duboff likes
dynamic positions but dubois great
player can play all sorts of positions
here a little bit on defensive there is
a threat to win the pawn back and
white's just going to try to dominate
mainly the c5 square so bring the
knights around to take complete control
of c5 but we'll move on to the next
board now um
ivanka and this one
well i have to say
uh the player from hungary is playing
quite possibly the best first move
available
f5 i don't think
ivanka will agree with that but we can
agree to disagree with the player i
think alex cannot play the best move
available i i think uh
knight c3
didn't quite play the best move
i think she will come to regret playing
that move and she'll perhaps
be far too harsh on my friendly f pawn
i mean uh it's it's you know okay a lot
of people hate the dutch um
and that's not the nation big scone now
but no it's actually the opening and
it it's a very dynamic way to play it i
know um that
the player from hungary has played the
dutch for a number of years but um
we'll see what happens knight c
this is her main repertoire so
it is
threatening e4 and you don't want to
allow that to happen so you try to
control that square develop bishop g5
ideas are taking that piece off and
going e4
so black
controls the e4 square
but gives a major hole on e5
e3 e6 knight square free bishop e7
bishop d3
and now both sides castle
and here i've always thought quite a
good way to play is like a6 and c5 or c5
straight away
knight to e4 i'm not sure i'd like
because in these structures where you've
got a big hole
you kind of need your dart square bishop
to control that so i think positionally
speaking
this exchange helps white in the long
run
knight e2
c5 and now a typical way to meet this c4
and after exchange on c4
the current position ivanka has it has
it gone that badly wrong
yes
do you want to think about that a little
bit
it doesn't look great i mean okay i
understand i'm exaggerating just because
i'm not a big fan of the dutch but
i i just i just think black's position
would be great
if you could
put that pawn back i just don't like
this big square i mean you've given
you've given i mean koreshka is a very
um positional player she's she's
aggressive but you know she understands
uh squares and i just think it's
unnecessary to give
the e5 square like that
i'm gonna have to slightly agree with
you in some of the things you said i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna agree that dutch
is bad opening because that'll just be
wrong we should have a challenge match
in the dutch one day wink week
um
you know i'm gonna lose you know i
remember once of going on this whole
spiel how hey the dutch was easy to beat
blah blah blah blah and guess what
someone played the dutch against me and
they they thrashed me
it has a time and place occasionally
i mean it any opening could be okay
can't it and the funny thing about this
move i really do see what you're saying
this position it creates this hole here
which you can't cover with f6 and it was
just off who's a fantastic player
originally from soviet union trained in
their traditional way of playing and
became a very famous trainer and he he
he talks about dutch defense it's a
famous famous story and he basically
said well the one problem with the dutch
is often the best move
is f5 to f7 so for example if black can
now go pawn back to f7 it might be okay
so that's what he said but i think
white's nicely developed and white is
now playing very sensible moves slightly
better for white i'm going to agree with
you i wouldn't play i wouldn't play it
in this way if i was black i wouldn't
exchange that bishop off but we'll come
back and see yeah no i i like to correct
c4 so let's move down to uh board four
we have another four nights here so this
is gara versus kostenyuk and
alexandra um
fantastic player uh does a lot of stuff
streaming uh chess.com always plays
title tuesday being women's world
champion this is a hard game for
garo isn't it with the white pieces this
is going to be a real struggle and i'm
sure russia will be trying to notch up a
point on this board
and this is yeah you know kustanika is a
very dangerous player she has an
aggressive opening repertoire um i i've
seen christina play some amazing chess
i've also seen she can be slightly
erratic i i've seen some tournaments
where she hasn't done very well so she
does have those swings and um
just
just to kind of point out that she did
very well in the top division but she
did lose a game unexpectedly to a team
that you would have thought she would
have beaten it wasn't one of the top
teams it was one of the teams from
africa i think egypt not quite sure
on morocco i'm not sure
but uh yeah so she is capable of having
some downward swings
yeah i i think that's the thing with a
lot of creative and aggressive players
they tend to have more ups and downs
than you know
than other players because they're
risking things occasionally and when
you're playing weaker players maybe you
shouldn't risk as much as you would do
normally
um
the current position we're reaching
after bishop h4 it seems a standard
structure you get here ivanka we even
talked about this yesterday aronian
destroyed his opponent from greece
with the same
pretty much same position by
suddenly using these pawns to come
through the middle of the board and
at the moment there is ideas of d4
coming up yeah and
corstenia really doesn't have any
problems in this position whatsoever the
opening's gone okay for her i i would
say do you agree with anchor yeah i
agree i i like black's position in
general i mean i i really adore having
the center uh the porn center that is so
i don't see any problems with the black
pieces at all which is what i'm looking
for looking out in these kind of
positions in these snap assessments so
i'm looking at how easy it is for one
side to come up with a plan i'm also
looking at whether one side has good
development
and uh of course if there's any danger
in this position i don't see those
things for black no it looks okay
so now we're going to go down to the
next board
where we have essa pienko
against adam kozak and i guess this is
the junior board and
again when you're under 20 and you're
already 2600 you've got a lot of talent
you're going places
um
espienko
very dangerous player he beat sergey
karjakin in a beautiful game in a blitz
world championships which i can remember
he's got the advantage of the white
pieces here so again we're going to go
through the opening quickly
which is
what we call a trendy regauzing position
where
both sides are pinning each other in in
different ways
and black's main play is the c5 move
black tries to get active
the queen on c2 is stopping the bishop
coming to that natural square
white develops and now puts the bishop
on f5
and we have more exchanges occur
the queen
nibbles the pawn on c3 defended
and now knights v4 trying to increase a
little bit of pressure there in the
position and
i suppose the big question here ivanka
is does does pianco have to defend c3 or
can he just get on with it in castle i
would probably castle without thinking
here even if taking the pawn was
worrying um
i don't think i think don't think he
needs to worry about taking the pawn i
would definitely focus on development
and harmony so because the thing is
black does have a weak d5 pawn
so after castles justice just to kind of
say something yeah
um
knight takes c3 doesn't quite work
because of knight takes c3 and then you
queen takes and then you have queen
takes d5 so there is that issue i did
wonder whether
white could uh
sorry black could displace the queen so
instead of taking on c3 perhaps throw in
some kind of
g sexes
jesus i mean g6 is one of those you have
to be so careful about playing i know
moving the pawn in front of your king
i mean it's nice to set up these little
traps but
no one should get carried away with them
i mean yeah it might not even be very
good either because
here you could get mated i mean like
queen h3 exactly
and i guess if i guess if castle's g6 i
put my queen immediately on h3 which
has a little bit of pressure against
this square
um exactly i know i mean i wasn't
entirely being serious but i just kind
of wanted to say that you know g6 is
as black it's happened it's happened
it's happened
yeah it happens you're thinking you're
thinking like a young superstar
i'm thinking hoping for the knight d2
so which essa pianko very very you know
amazingly avoided with queen h3 no i
mean i was a bit careful about playing
um queen
uh g6 because of the weakening of the of
the dark squares but okay yeah you do
have to be careful
this kind of structure i mean again
whenever anyone out there if you're at
home you're trying to improve your chest
you're watching this you're you're
wondering you've really got to look at
the structures and pieces that's what
chess is about so look at the pawn
structure what both sides trying to do
long run middle game ending and where'd
your pieces want to go and here
the thing that blacks often tries to do
he has this majority of pawns three
pawns versus two
and if you can get this pawn motoring
he's going to create a very strong past
pawn you can imagine that one coming to
b4 you capture it and that c pawn's
really good
now white doesn't have as dangerous
pawns but the black king is a target
and white can try to either break with
e4 or start coming up the board you know
just go for the king f4 f5 bang bang
bang
so it's going to be an interesting game
this one
did you know um you know as i've spoken
on um earlier streams about the armenian
school of chess and of course the soviet
school of chess but did you know there's
a hungarian school of chess do you know
how that one works out
so when we say school of chess we mean
everyone every country's got their kind
of individual style yeah okay so what's
the hungarian aware that this even
existed until i i was on a bus with
peter lecko and he was laughing and
telling me about the hungarian school of
chess which is they they have their
openings all worked out very nicely so
you know
if after move 22 everyone has played the
correct move regardless of your open
your rating it will be a draw
because you know what to do your
opponent played everything perfectly
um however
if you make a mistake in the opening
even in your 2700 doesn't matter the
hungarian the 2200 hungarian will play
on
that's the hunger
okay
you sure that's not just the liko school
of chess
i mean that sounds
i mean
i have it on his uh i mean he's actually
a great uh storyteller so he is he's a
fantastic player fantastic commentator
story the storyteller and uh
what i think about that is um him and
judith pogar judy pogart incredible play
and she was such an aggressive player
she's quite the opposite to peter liko
in a way you know peter liko very
correct judet
absolute firecracker over the board you
know so it's interesting to compare
their sort of styles the last board um
and now is
i believe the women's on the 20 board
we're go freedom who's at speed
and hungary with the white pieces this
might be a board that hungry
we're gonna try you know i suppose
before the match the captain will be
thinking subconsciously or consciously
which boards am i kind of relying on
getting a point on because some of the
pairings are like oh dear that's gonna
be tough some of them are like oh okay
maybe yeah and potentially this is one
board where you know i would you know
i'm not saying anything about the
russian player but you might hope white
pieces
could get a point on this one well
it looks like that because of the
chess.com ratings but i think uh paulina
is one of the strongest uh junior
players
in the world
so
yeah it's going to be easy i mean i
think on every board hungary outraged i
mean elo wise is just such a strong
russian squad uh but they've got this
far e4
interesting position you've anchored oh
yeah i mean this is a fight with black
going through the center
and white has made quite a lot of
progress over here got a nice night here
uh it's like a reversed a reverse benoni
and black's just gone for the sacrifice
of black sacrificing this pawn
maybe to rely on the d-pawn causing a
lot of trouble but i i don't know i
don't i feel that black's not
particularly well positioned to start
sacrificing normally in these positions
you'd have much more activity
right so i don't know at this point this
looks a little bit premature to me um i
mean in terms of like this bishop on c8
i would rather that they were out out
there supporting this push so um
i agree with you it does look a little
bit premature
and white has just grabbed that pawn so
is black's idea normally this sacrifice
and this is a very common idea you get
this the other kind of round you want to
often start an attack with like f4
um in this position and you want to get
your queen over here and just start
using but the problem playing f4 is this
is just the positional idea it might not
work in this structure is the e4 square
is beautiful and white has the square
for the rest of the game so
the reason you play e4 first is after
takes you often play f4 yeah to not give
that square and to try and open attack
this didn't happen if anchored by the
way d3 was played maybe with ideas
knight d4 is it going to work who knows
yeah that's going to be an interesting
question
breaking news um i think
a lot of you have already gathered this
in the chat but now we are allowed to
announce it breaking
rather sad news
and
um
well um
we have
the appeal that armenia placed they lost
the first round of the two-game match
against india because one of their
players was disconnected and they
appealed about this connection and
saying it wasn't there necessarily their
faults i think the appeal was rejected
um and rather than playing the second
leg of that match against india they
decided to withdraw they have withdrawn
from the whole competition
now
i don't
know that that's ever happened before
that a team has actually withdrawn from
olympia because a decision went against
them uh you can see
now on the screen
that india have progressed so india have
gone through to the semi-finals you
can't play it's nothing to do with india
nothing to do with anyone else it's just
a very unfortunate situation you make it
because
stuff happens
it's quite devastating i mean in terms
of chess because the armenian armenia is
a great country
you know i i really
and you don't want to
if they had been knocked out fine but uh
i just
yeah
yeah i agree yeah i i kind of
something more i mean i would rather
that these things that they played the
second game and uh
seeing how it happened because we did
see like in hungary against germany that
the germans managed to win the second
match and
yeah
just uh
talking
so i totally agree i mean we had lev uh
on the show yesterday after his win and
armenia progressing you can watch that
interview somewhere um
look on chess.com and he was basically
saying how much it means to the armenian
how proud they are of their chess
heritage and this is a big event for
them you know they've won the olympiad
before it's massive for them the
nation's behind them so it's going to be
heartbreaking for armenia to have to
feel that they they need to withdraw
from the competition um
as well so
it's very sad very kind of sad news that
it's ended that way but you know it's
the decision that they've made so you
know yeah yeah
entirely from a chess point of view um
can we check out the game you know ian
apomiati against erdos because i'm
having a quick
glance at it and it looks
like things
looks like we might be in for a very
very quick result actually
okay so whizzing through the moves
and
both sides playing kind of normal
looking moves now yeah max seems moving
that queen a lot but okay
now the knight takes that square
the rook has to lose tempo now a very
nice move here
c5
yes
i think perhaps
maybe it was missed
i think so this move this move is really
strong with anchor isn't it yeah
i agree it may well be missed because
you generally you have to take a pawn
like that but after d6 you you resign i
feel i mean rook to d7
yes
queen f5
yeah g6
yeah and then queen takes e5
and everything is on everything is
hanging
yeah yeah
so
that's a bit of a shocker c5 and you
can't take that pawn but yeah that
pawn's a big pawn when i say you can't
take it black felt he had to take it
with the rook
and you can see nepo on the camera very
nice gaming chair he has there very
funky
yeah funky gaming chair
uh yeah i like it might get myself one
of them
and
and now what of course black is the
exchange down but not just the exchange
down
look at that move rook to c8 and after
bishop d8
more tactics
knight takes e5 and nepo is as sharp as
anything
you have to take this one and pray
and the point is you know you have no
choice you can't you know you just have
to okay i might lose but i'm gonna take
it the queen comes in and now
all queen takes e5
king to d7
this is a question for the audience what
did nepo now play the next move is
pretty pretty fantastic yeah
um
i don't know if it works but it just
looks fantastic i'm assuming it does
work
and the next move is anyone see it
in the chat what would you play if
you're white here would you take the
rook when black takes your rook or is
there something better
rook
to
c6 oh
you must have enjoyed playing that one
yeah it's a nice move isn't it
it is and after pawn takes the point now
is you take here with check
the king can't take this one because you
lose your queen
yeah and not only that your rook is
still hanging on h8 everything's
dropping you have to go back
and now after queen takes h8
you can't take the pawn on c6 because of
d8
so knight to f4 and now queen to e8
and the idea is just to go queen d7
check and then take on d8 so for example
h5 we go check push the king away
take the bishop win the game and i think
yeah this is over this is gonna be a win
yeah it will be a win for why i'm just
trying to see the way forward after
knight e6
so knight to e6 i mean is it
wow you mean at the very least you can
even go queen takes f7 and just
start munching just start munching on
something um
yeah
i'm sure yeah always so shall we have a
look so it's going to look like uh a win
for russia on board one
okay well but by the way we'll just show
you one more move b4 was played juventus
okay black is paralyzed and white's just
gonna you know slowly come up the board
uh this can't really be taken because
black's losing control yeah we can move
move on definitely yeah let's move on to
uh gledura against duboff
so
so glendora is very
strong young and solid player he's he
likes his positional pressure so let's
have a look at the position
and him of course is one of chess's
creatives
indeed this is where we are
white support up person we can say but
black has used harry to the maximum and
slam dunked it into h3 that's got to be
worth at least a rook maybe a little
exaggeration but
it wishes okay he wishes he wants to
become a queen
but he can't quite yet
no
does black have enough compensation for
the porn because if white can capture
the h pawn
i would say no this knight on d4 is
absolutely stunning
because you cannot get rid of that
knight the knight controls a lot of
squares stops of rook coming in
controls f3 or something you know it's a
really good night
so does black have the compensation
ivanka rooksy free played yeah so just
to kind of confirm uh and ian napoli
actually did in fact uh
victor addos
i do wonder here in this position
whether a4 is something to
well maybe uh maybe a4 is
so like so a4 yeah maybe a4 is just too
computer-like
well if you can play like a computer you
you should it's always good to play like
a computer a4 yeah just just simple
chess
is there a simple way of doing this
what's wrong with taking the pawn what
am i missing
okay
i want to take the pawn i see a pawn i
take a pawn
and now is the idea that black takes
here and goes queen e4
that would
that would be what i would guess
so i want to take with a queen because
if i get the queens off i'm completely
winning the white
but now queen e4 is quite annoying
maybe
computer says no
computers are never impressed oh we have
this one
king h oh no we don't oh no
i was going to say queen b1 but then
you've got you can probably retreat all
the way back to f1 actually
yeah can you see a good move here for
black
boom oh
that'd be embarrassing and then and then
obviously queen takes you g2
yes okay so sorry after okay yeah but he
hasn't played this he's just gone rookie
one and maybe we'll stick with the game
we've been called champion um
and now knight's g4 and jupoff's doing
jubal stuff isn't he's getting ready to
to sacrifice something somewhere on one
of these two squares
um
dangerous to face this in a quicker time
look at the time i think is that 45
seconds
it's 45 seconds
by the way ivanka there's another result
russia have gone
another point up
with the chess queen
winning in
nice style i want to just show a couple
of moves here because it's very nice how
this occurred obviously uh alexandra is
winning here and
soon
look at that move lovely move d4 opening
up the bishop
and
look at those pieces stunning pieces
um okay sorry we go back to g boss game
now two nil to russia already not
looking good for hungary
knight g4 played in this position
yeah
um
okay
it's complicated this one i mean i i
would be quite scared with both colors
because
if i was black i'd be worried that i'm
just going to lose on my pawns but if i
was white
i'd be keeping a close eye out for all
of these moves
and
the question always remains can you take
on b5 and
the time is critical as well
yeah the time is very critical i mean
they do say it's easier to attack than
defend but still
time worries me because you do have to
be slightly precise here
right we'll move on now this is the one
where
the
yes
and the dutch wasn't looking so so great
here
lots of exchanges occurring though
but uh
black is surviving that's right
this knight though is dominating
dominating the board
it's a bit like uh jubos night
um which was on the same square remember
drew buff had his knight on this square
yeah yeah and get your knight to central
square is generally very strong
and now the knight is keeping his
control in the center of the board i'd
rather be white here yeah undoubtedly
you know the night knights love posts
and i can just see the night coming to
e5
and uh
yeah
it's uh it's a difficult
position and just looking at the clock
times as well
black is slightly down on the on the
clock
yeah oh okay i would i was expecting
knight to e5 but okay knight to d4
such a lovely square isn't it i mean it
stops black ever coming into the
position
the bishop is useless now this actual
advance maybe has made black's position
worse because black would like to at
least get that
piece doing something on a4 yeah and now
you've actually moved your pawn
advancing your pawn is not always good
and you're blocking the bishop so if you
just compare minor pieces yeah it's it's
looking i would say really horrible and
now i'm looking out for tactical ideas
actually i'm looking out for things like
um
i can see that if i get my queen to d4 i
would pick up this bishop
right 3d4 check yeah
and so i was just looking for any
tactical shots i don't think that there
is anything because this queen b6 can
you go can you go knight e6 here you
could go knight i mean this
i mean just thinking of tactical ideas
this one
with the idea of winning the rook
is something yeah considering in the
game b3 happened the bishop now has to
move to bad square because if it was
taken
very quickly show what could have
occurred here
well it's the same tactic just simply
take here and this queen d4
forking
and this is the problem this bishop is
terrible white's gonna win this game
white's pushing
black back and the knight is a winning
piece this is this is a case of good
knight versus bad bishop often the
bishop can dominate the knight but this
is certainly you want the night here you
want the night
um
it's not looking good is it for hungry
no it's not looking uh russia putting in
a very powerful performance now let's
have a look at essipanko and uh paulina
two and a half half to russia they only
need one more point so
and you have to remember you have to
remind everyone that especially for
those who've just joined it it's match
points that are important not game
points game points are irrelevant you
can win
six nil or three and a half and two and
a half that doesn't matter what matters
is the match point
yeah and this
let's look at this one board here is
there any hope for uh hungary getting a
result somewhere and
there are pawn up in this game but black
has the two bishops this is even not
looking
that amazing for whites
um
russia are really good aren't they
they've been very impressive they're
very clinical and
they outgrade hungry on every board but
i would i would go as far to say now
that russia are probably their favorites
i mean again i don't i haven't looked at
rating this is just my my opinion uh
you've got usa playing
that's going to be very interesting
always going to be a strong team uh
you've got ukraine in the competition
india i mean there's lots of good teams
but russia russia
russia very impressive i mean very
impressive yeah but i mean what i like
about this event again like i've said
many times it's just you know two men
two women two juniors so you gotta have
different types of strength
um because traditionally in the in these
olympiads it's always been like been
four
four men
and one reserve or four women and one
reserve and so there's like a strength
in depth here it's kind of you just have
to be able to have two good players two
or three good players and uh yeah
makes things a lot more unpredictable
yeah the time situation is not favoring
um the player of hungary either no
with only 12 seconds left at this moment
in time
and so is there any hope so
because if i felt that hungary could win
something it would be against oh okay
well now that's ended in a draw
let's see how it did finish ivanka so
it's complex position and white now
decided to take on b5 which is a move
you'd first look at
and in actual fact jubot decides to go
for the ending
because of the pressure that he's got
against um white's position rook f1 and
after f6 i'll be very scared to play
this as black but
black is tying white down to the defense
a4
g5 e4
and now king g7 and i suppose the point
is here black's just saying you can't
make progress
if you go a5 maybe i'll grab it your
back rank is very weak because of the h
pawn and after knight d6 knight rook a2
knight to f5
they agreed to draw which is good i mean
in a sense of the
match result another good result for
russia yeah another good another goods
so they have uh russia have three points
right
three points to hungary points so
hungary willings to win
the remaining games
both games yeah
and that's not going to happen
let's say you're playing in this
position and ivanka and you know that
you need to draw to to put the team
through but you know obviously you want
to win um do you offer a draw here as
white when you know you're doing well
but you avoid you know any any uh any
potential blunders or do you just not
care and play for the win what would you
do
well
well yeah the problem is that there's
not so much time here
um i mean they're playing with 15
seconds and if i only had 15 seconds on
the clock i really wouldn't be thinking
about the match result probably i would
just be thinking about surviving and
just playing moves and if your opponent
offered you a draw and you knew in a
match result
yeah then i if i knew that much as well
i would probably take it
um
yeah for the team you know if it's you
you do what's best for the team
so i mean it it's the same goes you know
when you're playing in a team
competition and you you get given seven
blacks
okay you just take it
seven blacks and two whites whatever
you you you're playing a team
competition
do what needs to be done and the more
more moves have been played here as well
the harder it is actually to to go for a
draw because your position is just so
good so good right it's so good you
can't really take control yeah i don't
think black would be offering a draw i
think that's the thing
i mean i once offered a draw against
harriet hunt just to qualify for next
round the knockout when i was like plus
five i just thought come on let's have a
draw and we will you know try to go
through but
this is obviously just winning but it's
just about the night the whole thing and
there was a lovely little maneuver just
like to go back to that point which i
thought was actually very clever the
dutch did not work well uh obviously
white's gonna win this one
and this was a nice positional point uh
in the game
um where black tried e5 so we go back
here
and if i can't find it sorry
where white's got this fantastic knight
and after e5
yeah which
black's trying to do something a really
nice maneuver white just
makes that pawn move again
and whatever happens the knight is going
to pop back to its great square and it
just pops back now and this wins the
game it's just that night
it wins the whole game
um so positionally very very clever
white's winning we'll have a look at the
other game going on black is also now
winning here so is black winning here is
it whose move is it yeah yeah there's
winning yeah like winning somehow other
we've lost white has lost a piece
domination domination absolute
domination russia has shown here really
strong performance i mean
i
i can't see
i have to say i i can't see uh hungary
competing with this show dominance at
the moment
no they they need to they they need to
play in a different style that's clear
yeah take some risks do something it's
easy to give advice not easy to do
against
a strong team
this is obviously clearly over um and
you're gonna remember that white needs
to win this game
and black needs to win this game in
order to level to level the score
[Music]
that's a miracle level i think yeah it
is
so white could take the draw here the
perpetual to make sure they go through
but you can't i mean this position isn't
too good
yeah exactly i mean there's zero risk
that you're going to lose because it was
there was a one percent risk
no
there's always a one percent risk
that you might blunder your queen we've
seen we've seen wow
we did we did in fact see that we saw
sagittarium blonder so that's true but i
mean
i i find that very difficult to believe
yeah
at some stage you've got to have
confidence in your ability to win i must
admit i also had a situation like you
did where i was completely winning and i
took a draw just so i could progress to
the next round and i regretted it you
know i was a piece up and i was like
yeah i should have just and then there
we go i think we're going to see um
black is going to resign like we'll
resign yeah definitely yeah i kind of
regret it as well i mean even though i
think you've got to put these things out
of your mind really when you're playing
but
i don't know i mean elo's also important
um
the only way
that this could be saved if it is for a
stalemate if you imagine a rook getting
around here trying to
is not going to happen
this is not going to happen i mean okay
and there we have it so 5 1
to russia so uh russia have won the
first leg very very comfortably have to
say
yeah i mean
dominating that's probably the most
dominant match
in these you know uh qualifiers for the
quarterfinal in the quarterfinals so far
they weren't in trouble in any boards
maybe you could say duboff was slightly
worse but it was a complicated position
and uh they completely crushed hungry to
be honest very very impressive
yeah um they are an impressive team
yeah
yes okay so we got the schedule um and
we can bring that up a bit later on but
for now
we're going to have a break very shortly
uh before the second part of this and
hungary got a real uphill struggle
they're gonna have to try to pull some
major rabbits out of a very large hat
to have any chance and even then
the rabbits might run away
[Laughter]
they're going to struggle i think is
what i'm getting at so um so yeah your
vanco i think we're going to take a
short break and let's take a break yeah
sure soon
so
[Music]
well we're back and we're back with this
match between russia
who seem extremely dominating the
russian camp of chess is coming at
everyone in the 2020 online olympiad
first of its kind and uh yeah the second
match is going to start quite soon
ivanka right yeah i mean to be honest
with you our the first match of this
russia versus hungary match just looked
like business as usual for for russia
they just dispatched everyone with
ruthless efficiency
yeah
i think i think it's the right word
efficient very efficient yeah incredibly
efficient
yeah
i mean judging by that powerful
performance i really
don't rate hungarian chances at all
um they'll have to
change they'll have to go for a
different strategy i mean
playing quietly didn't really work for
them so perhaps they would perhaps shake
it up and perhaps go out there and give
it all they got and play some aggressive
lines and uh we'll see we'll see what
they managed to produce
yeah i totally agree
it's very hard to change your style
though isn't it i mean especially when
you're playing such a versatile team as
russia
russia they can play positionally or you
know tactically they they're very good
at every area of the game
so i don't i don't fancy their chances
either you never know it'll be a major
upset if exactly i mean the showman in
me is like i want that upset i want that
armageddon much i mean i really love the
drama but uh
i just
don't see that this that it could even
be a possibility and that sounds quite
harsh but uh yeah yeah i agree
and yeah interestingly we just we're
just hearing the next round is going to
start very soon so don't go anywhere if
you want if you want to see
team russian in destroying mode again
then you're probably in the right place
for that and gotta feel for hungry a
little bit i mean it's a very tough ask
for them
we're hearing though there's lots of
changes in the team we you can see the
results there on the screen uh already
but the the team okay
so one big thing is that we can see the
man of the hour yesterday's man uh
thomas banoosh is uh playing
against ian apomiacci
yeah so he was the guy who got them
through in there in the playoff and that
was the most amazing armageddon game
i've ever seen yeah because thomas won
when his opponent when he had point
three not three seconds point three of a
second left right ivanka i mean that's
that's crazy point three i know
absolutely crazy
so there's been like huge shake up
actually of uh both teams like line up
so we have for hungary the changes that
i can see is uh petra papp and gara
tisia are now in and there's been a
change on the bottom board for the
junior girls that dorina demeter is now
in and uh the changes in russia as well
artemyev is in
katarina lagna in
but is this a good strategy
i mean should you be changing a winning
side
i think when you're as confident as
russia are and um their
substitutions don't look too shabby to
me either i mean you had uh geninas an
absolute animal at blitz chess she
destroyed the field in the english rapid
play championship she's one of the best
rapid play players around
they're good substitutions and i think
it's nice to you you're just showing
your power
you're like okay i could play this team
i could play that team we can play we
have many we have many strong players
who will destroy everyone and it may be
also they're thinking for the later
rounds they're thinking okay well look
we're favorites to win
so why don't we keep our opponents in
the next round guessing
and i think that's an important tactic
maybe we can bring up the the actual
who is playing who because we we now in
the next round so the semi-final um
which will happen tomorrow quarterfinal
quarter final we know already that india
are playing in the quarter-final let me
get this right who india played the
winning winner of this is that right
so yeah i
think so
so maybe they're sort of thinking okay
russia thinking we're very likely to um
win this one so let's change teams so
when we play india tomorrow they're
gonna not have an idea which board and
who's going to play you know maybe it's
a very crafty tactic so yeah i mean it
could yeah
that could be an idea as one also that
everyone is not rusty as well everyone
has had some experience
so uh yeah i got that sorry i've got
that slightly wrong event it was um
russia the winner of this is going to
play either usa or ukraine that that's
my bad there
as we can see now on the the table and
india are going to play either poland or
azerbaijan so so actually russia can
have a really tough match tomorrow usa
or ukraine yeah so
yeah it will be tough yeah
yes yes
um
usa and ukraine is going to be played
later on so we will be seeing that if
you if you stay here after this match um
be a little break and that match will be
shown later on as well um this is going
to be an awesome awesome match yeah
yeah it will be an awesome matchup as it
will be happening at the same time as
azerbaijan will be playing off against
poland so we will be covering both of
these matches
at the same time
no problem
so we're going to be yeah 12 games 12
games maybe we won't be talking about
the
details of the opening so much
do you think we'll see any armageddon's
i mean i already had high hopes that
today we were going to see an armageddon
uh some
because yesterday let's face it it was
just brilliant
it was the drama was fantastic i'm going
to say we're going to see an armageddon
in usa versus ukraine it's gonna come
down to one
one
game on one board i think that match is
so gonna be so close
both incredibly strong teams i reckon
that could be an armageddon what would
you reckon armageddon anywhere
yeah i can i can i can see an armageddon
happening um
there
i think there's a i would probably put a
60 70 percent chance for that i can
maybe also see and i'll begin happening
at uh
poland versus azerbaijan
two very very strong
sides there difficult to call that one
i think out of all the match-ups i think
okay the last two actually actually
scrapped that the last two matches that
we have remaining are going to be
incredibly tight i i i don't think i can
call it because you know usa okay they
don't have they don't have hikari
nakamura or um fabiano caruana but you
know they have wesley so on top board
sam shankland jeffrey song is a strong
strong junior karissa yip and iwang you
know it's just a these are big names
big big names big names so yeah it's um
but you know
let's let's remember ukraine have what's
that
one what's what's he called kevchenko
chefchenko can you believe that he has a
score of seven and a half out of eight i
think
he's he's awesome and they've got
another guy isn't he named after some
dole
some doll that kills people
chucky chucky
chucky your voucher eventually he hasn't
been doing so well but i mean the thing
is with chucky is that you know he's so
fantastic it just depends on which evan
truck will show on the date it could be
a brilliant you know could be brilliant
masterpiece could also be someone who
perhaps doesn't have a great day but i
think uh
i'm hoping for the magician to show up
the magician yeah or the killer doll the
quote simon
yeah i mean uh i have been called chucky
in my past believe it or not
with the ginger hair um but also i mean
just it's going to be a great match
korriboff is on board two for ukraine
and america very america got very good
strong young squad
but ukraine they do as well so um i know
there's gonna be lots of people from the
us of a
uh really anticipating that match
first of all
will russia struggle in this next one i
don't see it i mean if you were the
captain of hungary then ivanka what
would you say to the team okay so you
know you're playing russia you've lost
the first one
what would you what would you i want to
hear your team talk oh this is going to
be interesting
yeah come on imagine i'm one of the
hungarian players and you've got to talk
to six of us we're a bit down after
losing we're playing russia overdue
captain
well it's really important to get a
positive mindset so i would be
definitely something along the lines of
you know i love that quote actually i
think that was written on kasparov's
wall
which are they they they had this little
poster made for kasparov and it said if
not you
then who and and i like that kind of
idea you know
if it's your time guys if it's not you
then who will it be so just give it
everything just give er you know give it
absolutely everything
and focus on just playing in good chess
i would even say don't worry about the
team just play for yourself
play your heart out
and uh yeah let's see how it goes
but uh yeah russia is just so
efficient for the russians i guess i
would just say um
keep doing just keep doing what you're
doing
yeah
have some have some russian tea
so what do we reckon people do we reckon
that ivanka has the future as as a chess
coach
i'm not a very good
chess
pirate but i will see i disagree the
games are off by the way
the game's the games are wrong the games
are off and we can see that there's
already a grandfather
uh
and uh all the games seem to have
started now so this is the ball one and
uh as uvanka said it's a main line
grunfeld where white
gets the very big center but black has
this active play against the center
uh bishop v5 one of the trendy ways to
play at the moment against the grim
field just trying to cause some uh sort
of disorganization in the way that black
defends against this
um
so they're banging out their theory
they're banging out the moves here
um
yeah i mean i i agree with you if if i
was the captain of hungary i'd just say
like enjoy yourself you know you're
probably gonna lose
so you can do it guys
make it happen
yeah just enjoy yourself done yeah
so
okay so
well
i'm just having a look at the other
boards because we might as well stick
this with this one i guess until they
slow down a little bit
clearly
all theory here
um
they're both playing their moves very
quickly
yeah of course i wouldn't say i mean
that'd be bad bad team advice you're
probably going to lose
you know i've had that i've had that
said you're probably going to struggle
but you know
people think that they they're they're
amazing there's like a words of
encouragement
but then on the other hand you don't
really want to if you're doing really
really well
you don't really want to be told oh you
actually there's a chance that you guys
might win it because then suddenly you
get pressure you just want to be told
okay fine just enjoy what you have to
focus on the chest
and the rest will take care of itself
yeah
well
thomas has come out very confidently
here he's gained time on his clock he's
obviously prepared this line before
let's remember these grandmasters are
good they can and they might pull up a
surprise
um
he's going for it potentially offering
a pawn sacrifice on c3 if black decides
to go for this one
then you know this is brave play and
this is what they need to do they need
to take risks if they're going to win
they can't be scared of russia they just
have to go at them give some pawns away
attack enjoy themselves so yeah so
i mean one of the things that i think we
have to really stress is that hungary
have some amazing players you know it
just it just you know russia made it
look very very easy in that first leg
but uh
these are very very strong players
they're grand masters and international
masters they can play great fantastic
chess so i'm hoping that uh
that hungary managed to pull it out of
the hat pull those rabbits out of the
hat
we'll say a quick hello to matt carr and
the chat as well and everyone else who's
in the chat we're vaguely looking at the
twitch.tv slash chess chat so if you
have any questions you want to throw us
or anything like that then then just
give us a shout out
nepo decided not to take the pawn
instead he wants to create his counter
play straight away
now guess what i play here without
thinking without khan hello hello h pawn
i would go h4 without thinking i'll just
play this come on get out of it here it
comes throw it up yeah and and the the
bar slides
and the bar slides oh don't get obsessed
with the bar leave the bar out of this
the poor old that's the only thing that
we can see we can see the bus that's
slow sliding
slowly
i think everyone obviously everyone in
the chat can see it as well and
uh we don't use a computer i think
that's obviously very clear
um but i'd probably just shove that up
there and have some fun there you go but
anyway uh c4 is probably more normal or
bishop c2 let's look at the other boards
so the next board
is um artemiev who is really good he won
gibraltar which is the strongest open
and he's playing against gledora
and this is uh
an english i always used to play the bot
finnick english
opening
which is quite a positional idea and the
strategy that white adopts here is light
squares basically
white has this light square control
in
the position and
black on the other hand tries to go for
some dark square control yeah probably
is going to suit glenn gledora a bit
here do you think yeah i think so he's
positional very uh positional player so
i absolutely think it will suit him um
it's a bit of a slow game for my liking
i mean and a little bit too blocked i
i've never ever felt comfortable in this
type of positions because there's four
minor pieces on the or for each side
and i think i would prefer if there were
three
minor pieces some kind of exchanges so i
could kind of get to grips with the
there's not
not that many natural pawn breaks either
so
um it's quite standard so far i think
yeah i mean about maneuvering
one of the main ideas that white tries
here is something like bishop to one of
these squares
queen to one of these squares and then
try to get rid of the dark square bishop
this is the main
sort of positional idea from white white
would love to get rid of these two
bishops why would white lights do that
number one black's control of this
square becomes less but more importantly
this is the main long-term defender of
the black king so you're getting rid of
a good a good defender there and if you
get rid of this piece these kind of
squares around the king are a lot weaker
they become undefended so this is
something white has to do you have to be
a bit careful i mean you can go this way
then black will probably put the knight
on d4
and i've felt when i've played this
position before that i want to be able
to meet knight d4 with knight takes d4
so if i go here here i can't now play
this because pawn takes d4 wins a piece
so
you can even consider putting a position
somewhere like here then if knight
before i can take it just really little
things to think about there yeah
because i think bishop b3 is the most
natural move i think
yeah
with the same idea of going queen d2
bishop h6 so it's kind of just you were
talking earlier that you know it's
important to know your openings and to
kind of know where to put your pieces so
i don't think bishop f4 is naturally
no bishop
forces it's a little bit odd isn't it
because you're kind of walking into
maybe a pawn push but yeah
if e5 happens well i mean i don't i
don't know if this is the best square
but
this also blocks black's pieces in i
mean you can even go d2 that's not
ridiculous you know but we'll wait and
see we'll wait and see how this goes
okay next game
um
and this is ganina vs gara
and i was just saying how strong ganina
is of blitz
real tough challenge again for gara here
um
pretty typical classical position this
ivanka maybe would just stick with the
current position
yes uh very classical position from the
queen's indian defense
so it's all about you know whether white
can
expand in the center so 97 is a little
bit
unusual i would say
just voluntarily giving up control over
the e4
square but um
she must have done it because she was
worried about c5 i mean it's much more i
kind of the plans that i kind of seen
that are a little bit more typical
are bishop coming to e4 and then just uh
yeah
and and then perhaps during some 97 but
uh yeah
we'll see it's it's a slow game i prefer
white to the minute
yeah totally great perhaps
perhaps we'll see f6 and and uh black
playing for bishop f6 and black playing
for e5
makes sense
maybe there's some kind of trick here
like let's say you play e4 and i think
this is why ganina played a3 first if
you do this move which is the most
natural you get a lovely center okay
yeah
maybe there's a d5 to think about bishop
b4 being
the the tactical solution for black
trying to win the exchange i mean even
here it's probably very unclear but yes
why risk it nina thinks go a3 i'm
stopping this move i can try going
over here later on the a3 is a little
bit odd i have to say i mean
your kind of instinctive reaction to a3
is to get a4 and secure a potential
square for your knight on c5
i agree yeah this this this a a4 is a
very nice positional idea
this one pawn
sort of controls these two pawns and
more importantly you have the b3 square
and if the knight gets to c5 so you can
imagine these guys come off it can sit
there
white can never play b4 which you often
should want to do because it's always on
pass on
well i also just wondered whether if
maybe we can even delay a a4 because we
can play bishop f6 first thing just uh
she still can't play b4
yeah
play for this move
a much more natural move uh than a3 as
you say would be something like queen c2
because you also have ideas and knight
g5 here which is a common tactic let's
say bishop f6
you can think about playing this move
when you threaten checkmate and you're
going to win the bishop on b7 because
black has to take this knight otherwise
it's checkmate over here you can see the
queen flying in
and then you get this quite nice
diagonal so that that would have been
a more standard way to play i feel
ivanka but a3 can't be terrible
bishop e4 and now rook d1 nice
centralized play
um
right next game we will go
to
adam kozak versus sarrana two or the
under 20s two very talented players this
is looking sharp
um
we had this queen's gambit position okay
we'll go for it quickly
standard queen's gambit and now that
queen a4 check is to force knight c6 to
stop the c pawn from moving
bishop g5 pinning
and now e4 bishop d7 queen c2 this is
sharp
isn't it this is this is good
so maybe this is the kind of position
hungary needs your vanquier yeah i agree
and they need to
because the thing is with this time
control um
you got to make it sometimes you got to
make it so the price of a mistake is
quite high
so you know maybe maybe you're worse but
you know if if one side
blunders
and it costs them the game that's good
um
you don't really want to get yourself in
a situation where the price of a mistake
is low like you you blunder but you know
maybe you just decrease your advantage
from slightly better to
slightly worse you don't want that for
your opponent you want those kind of
positions where mistakes can be made and
prove fatal
i think serrano just recently
i think he did he win um the leon
competition i should know because i was
commentating on that for chess.com and
the finals and i can't remember it was
only probably like a week ago i can't
even remember
oh there's such a bad memory of chess
play but i think he was he's he is one
of the up and coming guys in the world
yeah definitely
he's he's really strong
but saying that i like the approach that
adam's played here we talked about this
before have some fun
don't worry sack a pawn get the center
get a dynamic position complicate it go
for the win so
i like it
next board
let's have a look at katarina lagno
pap versus lagno and this is a berlin so
i'm not going to show it because i need
to stay awake
and
we have rook d8
right next game i'm sorry my best
i mean it's a very level actually i mean
i i i think
yeah
i think uh like uh lagno's has been very
business-like the team needs a solid
performance in order to go through she's
just neutralizing white with black
yeah and she might she might think okay
i i am higher rated probably more
experienced player to my opponent if i
don't do anything stupid i i will get a
chance
um exactly later on exactly but room why
why risk anything you know she can just
play
sensible chess
and if you know a draw is not a bad
result what uh you know it's she had the
black pieces
it's fine
looks equal at the moment definitely
and the last game which we haven't
looked at is polina who
won in a complicated game against dorina
um
with
a position probably coming from rural
lopez
where i like white quite a lot i feel
having a pawn on g4 rather than on the h
file really helps white yeah you always
think about
who's got the bigger spaces alakine
who said if you have a pawn on d5 you
told me to shavanka you know i you told
me this
i'll let you say it this is i learned it
from you and i learned you told me
what's that
was ever
ever was the one ah
you you're serious i've been going
around for the last four years since you
told me in gibraltar saying yeah
that's middle game but he he wrote he
did um he didn't die in the middle game
and uh he talked about how when you have
a pawn on d5 that the plan isn't to
attack on the queen side it's simply
just to expand
but uh here here is quite interesting
because um the player of the black
pieces that's one of uh hungary's
substitutions so in the first game it
was uh
okay and we'll see if i get her name
right
and now we have a
dorina demeter
yeah
um
yeah i can't believe that that literally
i've been going around saying alakine
said a pawn on d5 queen side play if you
have a pawn on e5 which is defended you
go for king's side attack so there you
go you should check your facts
i should i should listen and even then
so if maybe i said malachi it might make
today or whatever
any good historian will tell you you
should always
oh and maybe you'll tell me someone else
next time exactly
maybe you're good
never trust never trust um what they're
saying on the internet and it has like
abraham lincoln or something like that
yeah who are you going to say next time
you'd probably say oh it was actually uh
yeah it was capablanca
[Laughter]
the worst thing is that you've actually
said you've got a bad memory so
i know you're tricking me
tricking me with your uh with your ear
but now no one will know they'll go well
simon said he had a bad memory so she
probably didn't say it was alec
[Laughter]
so it's basically oh dear i'll check my
facts or maybe i'll just be quiet from
now on you know i won't say anything
it's the idea it doesn't really matter
who it is i mean it's nice to talk about
it but it's the idea and the idea is
important and this pawn is a cramping
pawn
and i like white's position a lot i mean
white can even start swinging the rook
over here and have some fun
uh against that killing
positioning white it looks great for
white it does so much
everything
and you can also go move the knight go
g3 and f4 you don't want to go f4
straight away because
after the exchange here you actually
help black's position because you give
away the e5 square and black can sort of
put the knight on e5
and your pawns are a bit ugly but if you
a positional idea would be to go g3 f4
and then take back with the pawn on f4
so you get three pawns like this it's
very nice for white yeah but i mean i
just love your idea as well going king
f2
yeah
king f2 and then you know maybe i don't
even need to rush with rick h1 i can
just simply ask some questions maneuver
my pieces to better squares
um no i really like wife's position it's
the dream
yeah i mean the only thing i can think
of is uh black's pawn breaks releasing
form breaks like f5 which white has
firmly under control and then you have
c
c6 and the other one i can see is b
takes a4 so as long as you have all
those measures deal dealt with then
i guess why is
why it's good
yeah why it's good
um so
back to um the top board and we're going
to see
how things are going
we can catch up with the moves around
here um
this was the grunfeld
with white now managing to swap those
pieces off but black starting to create
some counter play on the queen side
exchanges occurring
it's a little bit late now isn't it sir
you should have played that when i said
when the bar was swinging you know
if that pawn was already out there you'd
be a lot happier yeah i would be happier
if you're all in h6 but okay
yeah you know
poor old harry
it's a nice idea it's a little bit late
okay so now nepo is sacrificing a pawn
but to get a little bit of activity and
win the pawn
i suppose he's going to win the pawn but
he's not he's actually
playing well he's playing to win he's
playing to push uh he's playing charlie
let's pull her
charlotte indeed
c free and
it's a bit scary that one a little bit
scary that's something that you kind of
mentioned quite often is that the
quality of the pawn not not
how many quality not quantity yeah
yeah
and now
i mean i don't think white should be
overly
concerned yet because he's got a nice
little blockade of that pawn the rook's
going to be free it can't be too bad but
it's tricky tricky positions right if it
is that is also combined with um
white's king side isn't that stable so i
can just see that black can torture
white a little bit
because of these uh this weak king
so i can see something like rook c8
happening and then see for roxy coming
down to see okay well rook a4 we're
coming down to
c4 and threat making some
threats yeah it was true and between d4
as well you know these pawns are somehow
i would like to play f
it just just doesn't feel great to have
this queen on c2
the other thing black could try supposed
anchor is swapping rooks off because um
if black can let's say you you just
imagine removing these pieces from the
board this is a good way to think
sometimes because obviously exchanges do
come up in games you've got to think is
it good for me or good for my opponent
if it's good for you go about it if you
can remove these rooks from the board
then black
would have ideas of queen d2
and you can't really play queen d2 you
know in these kind of positions because
the white rook just controls that pawn
but if you can imagine the rooks are off
the board
that pawn could be a winner so not yet
another idea is is to go rook b4
um yeah euro would be tempted to go rick
b3
yeah try to force some exchanges of
course but you know even rook c4 and
then there's still queen d2
rook c4
and queen d2 is trying to be played
[Music]
yeah
he's going for it so he is going for it
nepo um and the other thing is nepo can
probably always take a draw by just
going for exchanges you know if he ever
goes queen takes e4 we have a rook
ending which will peter out to a draw
yeah um so certainly not worse for him
back to the english opening arts
and
we had a lot of action i think so bishop
f4 was played
i got a move right wow that's probably
the first time in the whole thing
and now knight to e5
queen d2 so we we we talked about this
idea but f5 gledora is
going for his own play
rook fd1
knight c6 and now a capture on c5
capture on f5
queen e3
h3 knight to e7
looks like look at gledora i can't say
it i can't say that name gledora there
you go has played this quite well as
well you thank her yeah i think so too
um
you're quite familiar with these kind of
english positions so to me it's a bit
foreign territory but uh yeah i mean it
does look like i like this maneuver of
knight to e7 i i i'm always a big fan of
swapping off this fantastic bishop
yeah but it takes bishop just to soften
up the king side that little bit more
yeah i totally agree i mean the queen
side bishop is nearly always
worth less than the king side bishop in
these positions and
this exchange does
normally help help the player of the
queen side vision
we have this annoying pin though on the
knight which
is annoying and maybe white can consider
some ideas of breaking with d4 at the
correct term
so it's still it's still
you know
interesting after i guess knight g6 is
is the normal move here yeah what what
do we do next we don't want to lose our
dark squared bishop because this piece
will become very strongly and so you'd
probably go bishop g5
probably
and
now you have to even worry about f4 in
some positions but queen f7 coming over
to b7 is is a demonstration of that you
know how why it's a good idea to remove
the king-side bishop
yeah
this could be quite uncomfortable
i i think it's it is you're right it is
a bit uncomfortable
so we had the knight coming the other
way that's a bit strange
but black is looking towards the d4
square
but it's less forcing because you're
leaving the bishop there and now white
does play this move d4
breaking in the center
um
so things will be clarified quite soon
though yep
next game
is
nina versus gara
this is getting interesting yeah and
around here we left it like this didn't
we we did and i like hungary are going
for it ivanka i'm actually really happy
whoever had the team talk did a good job
because you know they said look you've
got to go for it and g5 why
why
going for it i like it and yeah i mean i
mean the the thing is with gunana
valentino is that she is a very
aggressive player and sooner or later
she'll come for you so i quite like this
kind of reverse cycle kind of take a
different approach well i'm going to
come for you instead so i i like it g5
and especially with time control she
won't be able to find the most active
moves to defund
yeah i mean with f5 now coming up next
here they come
and look at this knight d2
bishop b7 e4 f4 love it
this is looking like one of my dutches i
i often meet e4 of f4 and i've had loads
of positions i
e5 and of course you should take here
now taking back would not be very wise
because then you get this square on c5
which ivanka mentioned before
and you can never get rid of that knight
so
nina has played bishop h3
rook f6 maybe the rook is going to come
around have some fun
yeah and also defense the e6 pawn
now
she's going for it
good stuff
and this is looking a little bit
dangerous for ganina and uh but let's
have a look at the time situation so
guinea has
one
extra minute on the clock
which is quite important you know it's
something that i keep paying attention
to because i know how how much of an
influence it had on my games
so i'm just transferring that really
yeah because people you know everyone is
watching this just remember ivanka was
playing in this event for england
so um she's had the first-hand
experience with vancouver so yeah you
can tell us a little bit about that i
mean how was it playing for england in
this event did you find it easy to adapt
tense no it was the difficult it was a
difficult time control you know i mean
for players like levon aronian who
played lots of lots of rapid play events
like this i mean i'm not really used to
playing rapid play i haven't really
played too much beyond the 25 minutes
plus five
and this one was a strange hybrid for me
i i didn't manage to
get my get used to it so to speak and i
can see things are actually heating up
because gunina has just played h4 so now
i'm just trying to work out
okay so black black's calling the bluff
and just saying okay i'm taking it queen
f4 f4
going here and now now something like
richie
i mean i i think black's doing well here
i'm really i like black's position quite
a bit
very impressive played by gara this is
what they got to do i mean they're
fighting back here you can even try
putting the queen on this diagonal brook
coming over to f8 this kind of thing get
all the pieces played yeah get every
single piece working um this is what you
need to do
great play great play
um
king h8 another idea get the queen over
queen f8
probably a good move but i know i mean i
like it because i mean if you if you
neutralize the attack you have your
extra material don't you
yeah maybe you don't one two three
actually
why can't even
i don't think white can even take the
queen off you thank you because after
rook takes f8 both of these pieces on
pre and black's just going to win a
piece yeah so actually queen f8 this is
a great game really good game from gara
she's playing great chess exactly queen
i know you caught where are you going to
put the queen
oh you have to bring your rook
do i have to answer these difficult
questions
but if you bring the rook there's even
tactical ideas like knight to b3 you
know and the rook
there's no square i think black is
crushing it i mean this is like a really
nice dutch kind of attack ah the dutch
attack this is this is the way to play
but it was but did you notice simon
f5 was played
on move 20.
not move well i i said gara played well
but she can still improve i think that's
what we can clarify if she plays it on
move one
it'd be a slight impact yeah okay
so we have a quick look at everyone else
because this is looking really promising
okay we're just great blast so this one
okay still going on this is glendora by
equal
this one um with nepo has now current
positions only times getting critical
gone into gone into an ending when nepo
has managed to
get to the queen ending and he's
starting he's going to pick up he's got
a bunch he's going to munch on the king
side pawn so f2 they're all dropping
aren't they
so yeah so it looks like russia plus one
this one gara is going to get back i
feel so equal
is there any chance what has happened
here so we just had queen queen c1
hungary are going for it and look at
this i'm coming for you russia bishop
takes h6 this is good stuff i'm sorry
armageddon is on the cards yeah okay go
on
i mean it's so nice to see like it's
okay now there's at least a draw white
has at least a draw here yeah but
remember hungary are in in a must-win
situation yeah
and they got white here but maybe you
have to take the draw i say draw so at
the moment it's still very even now okay
what happens if you thread and check
mate okay so okay
um knight g5 yeah
okay this all looks knight g5
threatening checkmate yeah it's always
nice i'm gonna raise the pulses just a
little bit
yeah it looks okay so i have to take
this one and i have to play queen to e7
to
defend like this and
the issue is you've only got two pieces
of attacking you normally need three
pieces in in a situation like this if a
rook can come around here
so yeah okay because i think it's going
to be a draw i i don't
think so i don't know
much as i love attacking i
i can't see
what's happening here it's playing okay
now next game
bad news i think for hungary that
lagno
is looking at let's let's count the
material because i'm thinking
that white is what what oh no it's white
supporting oh
hungry
hungry gonna create a miracle here
i mean i say a miracle beating russia is
is
maybe a miracle is too much but it's
they're fighting
they're definitely fighting and this is
what we want to see be i mean it would
be
what a story would it be if hungary were
to win this match and take it to
armageddon
and definitely winning chances white
because blacks black's bishop is useless
white is a pawn up
only issue is that black's queen is
quite active so you need to be yeah but
this picture 1v2 is a fantastic defender
so i mean if i go queen h
yeah i mean i can see that there's not
that many
i'm just trying to think of ways to
progress
by the way nepo has won but we expected
that one anyway yeah we did so uh
russia have gone into the lead with one
point extra and um i'm not sure about
that i mean i i wouldn't want to give
pawns back
i mean i think the idea is okay you give
the pawn back and then your queen is
going to come in here
so after bishop here maybe it's very
clever let's say queen takes h2 bishop
f2 and white's figuring okay i've given
one of my pawns back so i'm not
materialed up but how do you stop my
queen
now rampaging itself because if you ever
come out it's clever that's clever if it
works um let's have a look
oh by the way a draw offer has been
declined by white so well done for being
brave
another result it was a draw in that
attack ivanka so we had a perpetual
check here yeah one here but some of the
games looking very good what about the
last sport the last board have a look if
hungary are doing well here it could be
an amazing upset the last board was
looking tough for hungry and it is
it's still looking tough yeah yeah
white's piece is flooding in now diving
into the position
uh that e pawn scary scary scary
so
russia one up i think they're gonna win
here
so
it might still be tough
i think it's looking bad okay back to
this board here with
vladislav
and glendora needs at least to draw this
position
is that i think he thinks he needs more
than a draw right
um
it probably yeah i think he needs to do
a bit more than that because we suspect
that uh
well unless that board six pulls it off
you know manages to hold this
if that happens then uh
yeah
i mean what what we're thinking is it's
one and a half
to russia at the moment
uh remember if it's free all this match
russia go through
the board
we're pretty much
guaranteeing russia are going to win is
this one taking it to two and a half
meaning that this game black needs to
win this game here gara needs to win
he's playing fantastically yeah and in
this game white needs to win to keep it
keep the fights alive
so
quick another quick look at gara's game
by the way queen f8 rook g1
and
has things changed at all well
current position now
is there no knight b
threes in there and knight b3 you could
go rook
knight b three's been playing we've been
played rook d7
and
how about coming into f2 is this going
to occur
rook take this is all very quick
has this been played it's been played
um
this is on the board at the moment
the white rook has suddenly become very
active on the seventh franc it's a messy
position and the time is very low
yeah
no doubt about it that black needs to
win this game but it's going to be tough
anyway i mean whatever the result this
one hungry have come out swinging which
i think is great okay so now that the
knight is trying to come around is there
any way
black can try to create some check mate
nets because you've got sort of that's
what i was trying to work out just now
because i was thinking okay well if i
could get my bishop to f5 check
or maybe there's maybe there's a knight
to f5 as well and perhaps bishop g2
it feels like there's a mating net in
the air so rook takes c7
okay
and our bishop okay bishop here is is
get we're trying to weave that net
around the king this is definitely the
most exciting game i i think of of
what's remaining so we can maybe stick
with it
um
three pieces looking scary but no fear
oh oh
valentina is not scared is she she's one
of the bravest players but it doesn't
like lose a piece or i don't know how
long what's she working out so i was
thinking rook h2
rug yeah rook g2
rook g2 or rook h2 here
because if you're going to she goes king
king g3
so if you go knight f5 oh yeah just
there's three moves here either knight
f5 rook h2 check or rook g2 which looked
crazy let's try knight f5
well the time should we just see the
time is the twenty three minutes
into the attack yeah maybe we'll wait
and see i've read you two rookie two
actually i like that move rook g2
threatening the night she's gone richie
too
threatening the knight
and if she goes knight h3 well then
that's knight f5 checkmates
done yeah that'd be nice this would be a
well not a nice finish for
that there'll be a very picturesque
finish
so
but if we well how do we save the night
we we can
sell it to sell it quite expensively i
mean try to win some pawns
yeah i mean it's not gonna be enough
though the black piece is coordinating
well brilliant game from yeah brilliant
really incredibly game by uh
yeah very impressive
um
well
carsten124 is in the chat is saying
knight e2 but i mean if you play this i
worst case scenario
it should be good enough if i simply
just take the knight i mean there might
be some checkmate ideas but something
like this
it must be winning because i'm going to
take i'm a piece up this is yeah yeah
that's just uh yeah straightforward yeah
and now ganina only has 14 seconds left
and do we have any progress on oh
bishop said is she trying to set up some
oh this is really oh no she's falling
for it
okay no no but it's not it's you can
play king g7 and after rook it's it's
okay
i thought that was a
typical ganina trick there yeah yeah i
thought so too
touch okay so that's
so hungry will have struck back yeah
let's show that line so the point is if
rook g8 check
it looks like white's maybe picking this
one up but after and it has been a win
we're going to show brilliant brilliant
game there if rook c8 king here check
king takes f7 oh white's back in the
game but now this is counter punch
knight to f3 and you can see genima's
got up from the board there and black is
winning brilliant brilliant result for
guy they're really
very impressive play yeah so let's go to
the um critical game which was a cartoon
lag now
it might all be over though um i'll
lag no under top board so well okay yeah
we're going to lagno so
we need to white needs to win this one
right and the current position here
white has
some work to do still major time
advantage remember the last two balls
the two boards remaining
and this is one of the boards
white has to win here and the other
board
well somehow
glendora's got to win this ending if
it's a draw
here i think russia will guarantee
drawing the match which is enough to
take the title much closer in the first
round is there any way that black can
win this one
um
no is what i'm gonna say unless uh
unless white does something
yeah very
silly
i think white can always give the rook
up for the pawn exactly and then just
and just go for this a pawn so um yeah
this is going to be really neat
to
do something
yeah
completely logical so yeah this is going
to be a draw
yeah
which means russia would go through by
drawing the match
uh i think
at least drawing the match
um it looks like probably white is
getting near forcing the draw here as
well
it's going to be over very quickly
um
these you can see this rook will have to
give itself up
i mean i can see one way okay so yeah of
course like i was thinking if you went
f7
which was uh right
instead of a sub at f7 we have rook
takes f7
i think it's heading to the drawers but
even then that's still a draw
yeah i mean if you have to work really
hard oh look at time oh
okay
he got down to one second there that
could have been that could have been it
yeah that could have been that could be
three two
sevenths
we need a disconnect here we need a
disconnect or something okay but it is
okay so now he has to go okay eight and
now he has to run today yeah now it's an
easy draw it's a draw every i quite like
the switchback you know he goes from
king to d6 and we go rook a8 because
it's so important to meet
okay now the king can come now the king
comes and king of six
i don't think white should be trying too
hard to win this position
okay well now rick takes
and it doesn't really matter the result
of this game which probably would be it
looks like white is winning
yeah it looks like it as long as you can
avoid any perpetual check with your king
you can probably hide somewhere and um i
mean whatever okay whatever we can say
about russia going through incredibly
strong team major favorites on each
board that was a good that was a good
that was a great matchup
yeah it really was a fantastic they're
really important hungary really
impressed in this uh this round you know
they've especially the women players
they've really played out of the skin
they played confident
old chess
totally agree and i think you know that
gaara's game was one of the best games
i've seen so far in the whole the whole
of the competition i have to say she
she she went for it and she played risky
chess and
this is also looking like a very good
result for uh petra as well um
just have to find somewhere to move your
king to avoid the checks we saw this in
the armenian match i think you can put
it on
on g7 can't you yeah
in some ways it hinders black having
this pawn because black can't check on
the g file and white's gonna play queen
f6 to block any other checks queen the
pawn and then go queen f7 i think this
is the i think this is what i'm thinking
yeah and then you can simply put your
king on g8 so now you can intercept with
queen f6
uh i don't like this one you could go
and also king f but i think it's fine
because after queen e6 you can go quick
queen f7 done right okay that's your way
okay queen of seven and now yeah nice
nice
nice result
well done to well done petra well done
to
gara i mean drawing against such a
strong russian team yes russia were
through but that was a challenge and
remember if
if hungary nearly came within a whisker
of
forcing it into armageddon and i would
be honest in the armageddon anything
could happen literally anything you know
it's a big leveler isn't it simon it
really is yeah yeah it is
so but impressive well done hungry i'm
just gonna say it's unfortunate but they
really fought hard yeah very hard match
um
but saying that russia are through to
the next round
and russia are going to play the winner
of the match we can see here on the
chart
between
usa and ukraine in the semi-finals which
is taking place tomorrow and the finals
on sunday so we've got two more days to
see who is the olympiad champion
now later on today it's going to be more
commentary we're commentating azerbaijan
poland
and also on that big match usa ukraine
so
that's going to be fantastic i think
we will take a break very soon
um
and
we will come back shortly with uh well
we'll be to tell you what's happening
later on so
okay we're gonna take a break now and
we'll be back in
ten minutes or so okay okay then
so
[Music]
welcome back everyone and
it's the big one
the big match um and what i mean by that
is it's a match between america and
ukraine
so um this is one i think a lot of
people have been very excited about
uh ukraine pulled up a major well upset
in a lot of people's eyes by beating one
of the favorites china
and now they're playing against the us
of a who are also a favorite so
this is a big big big match um and
there's some big big big pairings so
we can have a look at them you've
anchored you want to go through some of
those pairings yeah i mean the big one
for me it's going to be wesley so
against vasily evanchuk i mean i just
love watching evan chuck play so but the
big question from him he's a little bit
of an erratic player which evanchook
will show today you know will it be the
magician who creates magic from you know
fans these amazing combinations you have
to remember he was also world blitz
champion or rapid champion i can't quite
remember which one
but uh yeah i'm looking forward to that
i'm also looking forward to anton
korobov against sam shanklin
and uh the female players of carissa yip
against julia osmak um one that i'm
really really excited about is um
jeffree xiong against kiro shefchenko
you have to remember shefchenko was
the man of the moment yesterday not only
was he a huge hitter in the top division
when he won all his games for ukraine
six out of six yesterday he got to one
and a half out of two and he also won
the armageddon game yeah i was so so
impressed so yeah i'm
really excited about this and we mustn't
also forget that there is a second game
happening at the same time which we will
keep an eye on and that is poland
against azerbaijan
and azerbaijan the favorites there
but uh yeah
yeah there's a lot going on there's a
lot there's a lot of chess going on now
so we're going to have potentially 12
games to look at now we are going to
concentrate mainly
on the match uh usa versus
ukraine
we feel this is the the big one but we
want to have a look occasionally the
other one but
with such match-ups as wesley so versus
a vantra
come on you can't really beat that can
you and um
they have already started uh your
vancouver and you know what opening it
is
it is
it's uh basically he went to touch
the c pawn and move up one square
but then you know there was some kind of
hand and eye coordination problem and so
he touched the e porn
it's a french
it's a french ivanka loves the caracon i
i i wouldn't say i love the french but i
play the french
and
we actually
have a position now which i i know i
know pretty well because um
i
played this variation of territory i
played it i suppose for like 30 odd
years
this is a more positional approach for
wesley he could have pushed on with e5
as well but you don't often see these
french defenses at top level i know that
gear is
just publicized something on the french
and
occasionally comes out and vanchak
very famously beat gary kasparov in the
french defense when gary caspar was the
world champion and the best player in
the world so
chucky is impossible to prepare against
he plays every opening
and he plays every opening very well um
so
lots of moves coming in this must be
theory already ivanka
yeah
it must be this must be quite theory i
mean it's it's kind of interesting
choice i think to kind of
take a little bit more of a solid
approach but you know i i remember if i
chuck discussing a position very similar
to this in his game against um
the tan jungie
was late in jay lington j one of the
chinese girls in gibraltar where he
found these amazing variations
and it was quite a structure very
similar to this so yeah
looking forward to this can we move down
see
how uh
shanklin against corabor for shaping up
yes so
we're going to go through the moves very
quickly now sam shankling is
um one of the leading uh exponents of
the slav the semi-slab variation
and koropov
sort of just saying okay i'm just going
to play some chess here korribos
a great player i think this is one game
personally when i look at it that if
ukraine have any chance or a big chance
they've got chance but this is one game
i think they they want they're going to
want the player to white pieces to win
if i was the captain we talked about it
before i'm thinking korobot great player
of white i know shanking's a great
player but you know push push with the
white pieces
and
[Music]
we now i mean sam shankman's openings
are fantastic
he he knows his openings so so well
standard kind of slav
stuff going on here this move very
important excuse me
they're still in theory
and
again you have to also remember that um
sam did a did a course on on the slav on
the semi slab
so uh
that's that's something that's always
quite it kind of gives you hope because
you have actually studied these
positions you know to great depth and
use all the engines possible so um yeah
sam must be feeling pretty confident
and
must be theory looking at the times i
mean just look at the time yeah
and not i mean not just the times but
how sharp this position is because black
has these uh
bishops which can cause a lot of trouble
and the knights
you want to be a little bit on guard
here with white
um you don't want to allow black's
pizzas to totally swarm in
corabos seems to know what he's doing
he's now gone for e5
and it feels really good for black to be
honest with you i mean i don't see black
has having any problems whatsoever um he
has good piece
development a great square for the
bishop on d4 the only thing that you
could potentially worry about is in an
end game i can see that if that bishop
on d4 were to disappear from the board
then of course he's pawn on c5 and b4
would be potentially quite weak
but uh yeah i like black's position
yeah i mean i suppose coriboss picked
this he probably knows that sam shanks
is a bit of a theory expert he's
thinking well okay look
again sam i might not get an advantage
in the opening because he just knows too
much so what do i do okay i pick a line
which i feel comfortable in might not
get an advantage and i don't think he'd
ever play a line where he thinks he's
worse with white would that just be
crazy
well you wouldn't deliberately choose
that but you might accidentally go into
it
i mean not spending 30 seconds on your
clock surely i mean he's moving very
quickly unless he's forgotten something
i mean it's not that bad is it i mean e5
this pawn structure is quite nice
uh yeah i mean it's quite nice but i
just don't see any problems for black
no i mean i don't i mean
okay there's the first the there's the
first issue is that i mean i
sam is thinking but uh
at least he's got it okay you can play
knight d5 right because a bishop takes
knight isn't possible because of knight
e3
this is a nice
little discovered check yeah wouldn't
win the queen
and the other nice idea as well you
don't want to take here do you either
look at these bishops
look at those killers look at them
they are the strongest bishops i've ever
seen in my life and those are the four
bishops aren't they
they are wow look at those guys so
so you're right so this 95 but now okay
he's playing quickly i mean this this i
i'm i'm i'm gonna say i i think corobot
knows his position he's confident and
he's he's looked okay would he play his
next move quickly
this is a sign
so
no sometimes sometimes you know it's
like a double it's like a bluff isn't it
you know he's playing quickly and you're
thinking well what is this but they're
playing quickly and confidently
um
yeah
okay h3 and now whoa hm
wow
let's do some quick calculation before
we leave so pawn takes knight
okay so i see a piece i take the piece
yeah you take it yeah and then black
take black sam's idea is obviously to
take yeah yeah and then there should be
four
you have to play bishop e4 let's just
show you can't leave this diagonal
because of knight to e3 so you have to
go bishop to e4 now is there some f5 is
maybe this sounds so well prepared okay
so if you play f5 i will i will be very
thankful that there's something called
the ampersand rule
to me i never really made so much sense
but you know okay
there's a famous story um
there's a very friendly story that
actually uh mickey adams forgot about
england's strongest airplane forgot
about the on passing rule when he was
playing neil mcdonald he lost because he
just forgot about it it actually
happened very late in the game so yeah
i'm thinking f5
kind of looks natural but
this is something else this is all
theory and so i mean his theory
yeah you're right maybe i'm scared of
being corrupt off here f5 i'll give it a
punch so you go on pencil on person yeah
and now i'm not sure why i do next i i
i
do i even go like rookie eight and just
say come on i'm gonna tell you i i i
think that's a nice idea actually
get rid of that bishop and i'm gonna use
these yeah i mean i don't like that idea
just forget about material and just
simply go okay well
it's that light square bishop that
matters to me the most
yeah this is this is uh you know what
this is maybe okay we have some more
moose so this has actually occurred wow
we've got it right we got it we put it
right sounds banging
virtual high five to you
with sound effects or elbow bump
you know okay oh yeah yeah
all that all that stuff and um this is
the power of the love power of love
power of bishops
yeah they're breaking it down you're
right maybe this is just shankling power
is that is that something do people say
that shanklin power
the king has moved off that diagonal and
he's banned out this move like f6
he's probably had this uh on his
computer like a couple of yeah
i think he's looking at him because he
can see him on the webcam over there
you know i've looked at this yeah he
looked up to the skies as if he was
trying to record something i it's uh
yeah do i detect some over excitement
there's just the speed he played rook
takes f6 i just wondered whether there
was some excitement there that he was
getting his moves in and that was uh
i mean it's a fascinating fascinating
position but it is this is this is
shanky power he's shanking him
shanking he's shanking him with his
bishops okay let's move on let me this
is faster let's move on before we
before i get ready
now another fact these games are great
now we have jeffrey versus kirill both
heroes and this is really exciting we
have a
bishop b5 czech sicilian
we have queen takes d4 and we saw this
earlier on where
it went horribly wrong for a player who
took with a queen bishop takes is much
more standard rook c8 e5
opening things up jeffrey real talent
really real real real talent
and now what is this move this kind of
makes me feel like i want to be sick
i don't know like i mean
you don't like f6 simon
i'm doing a ben finds
it may be a good move it just looks it
looks it looks ugly
it may be brilliant okay pawn takes d6
e5 so this is i mean i'd be oh i'd be
very tempted to whip that one off as
well
anyway this this i'm assuming theory
black
faced by queen beef i mean i don't know
queen b6 trying to win that pawn yeah
and again i'm guessing
okay i i i assume that white would try
to defend that pawn with all yeah is
this very i mean i'm not an expert on
this variation but this is this is a
this is a really weird position i mean
for example if black takes on d6 white
can at least play rook d1 and you've got
this problem with your bishops here
they're getting they're getting in
trouble if you take the queen
on this square which might have been an
idea well
black has to worry about queen takes
here yeah
yeah
so he's trying to get the queens off if
i was black i'd also be trying to get
the queens off because
your king is stuck in the middle white's
castle and you have it will take you a
lot of moves that ever get your king
safe
um
now i'd be very surprised if white
changes queensland yeah
yeah i would be very surprised because
there's knights uh on f3 and especially
the one on c3 they're just not well
placed
yeah and uh i can see that the black
king on e8 might not be safe in a middle
game but certainly safe in an end game
and it just
ah yeah so white has to
keep the pressure on so okay what kind
of moves will we
well i'm thinking i mean queen d3 looks
like a good move to me and now perhaps
you can take on this
now you just take on d6
and i don't want to exchange queens i
see no i mean i mean okay
backwards so let me just something then
what i mean i don't when sacrificing
this pawn if i can open it up let's try
queen b3
it's another square
yeah okay so now um now i can take your
pawn with the bishop maybe yeah yeah
and do i have any play you're quite
solid here maybe f6
f6 just looks so horrible but it
actually makes sense
um i still don't have a safe space clark
to get my king to safety but you know
details nothing i mean nothing i could
do your vancouver is okay i could go
rook d1 here and basically say all right
you're gonna get the queens off but i
still have my knight trap traveling into
your position it's not it's not too
tragic i i i think i like that one the
best thing yeah
let's move on because so far brilliant
gains now this one is a game between ria
and annie
annie wang is there american champion
um is that right well my thing is
someone else um no i think she is
american champion
very strong
under 20 um board
now this position looks like a fairly
um
whites played very solidly keith arkhar
would love this position where he's got
four versus three
and potential of a minority attack good
bishop on g2 bishop
white slightly better here i mean this
one's a lot easier to assess and you've
got this potential of going e4 e5 and f4
and just advancing on on the
on the channel santa really
so yeah i mean with the bishop pair i
think white has some nice long term
yeah advantage yeah i got that mixed up
i'm not very up with american chess but
it's jennifer's shoe
isn't it he's a champion
yeah
but i do remember annie wang did very
very well she got it very well
yeah
she did very well didn't she for her age
and she she excelled in it but yeah she
did this fantastic tournament that's our
i remember it was a playoff or something
yeah
okay now another game zakova versus um
hannah
and e4 just being played here um
which looks like a nice break to have
where white is trying to come through
the center of
the board
um
looks
slightly better for white i would say i
mean this is a normally a good break to
play and if black ever has to take it
then
white is guaranteed a bit of a better
pawn structure because these central
pawns
bishop very nice say
e4 looking looking looking like uh white
should be happy r34 yeah in this
structure
white is definitely doing
or has a lesson
um
what about
there's another female player board that
we've missed there's one more yeah and
it's this one here so
another very strong up-and-coming player
um chris yep and against osmak
this position a4 now on the board
again
pretty pretty even uh at first glance
i'd say both sides seem to have maybe
got ideas in that they wanted to get him
knights on good squares
this move played to undermine the
position
on the queen side and if you can ever
get this kind of exchange white would be
very happy generally as long as you
don't lose b2 you know yeah then you're
just trading weaknesses so um yeah
but wow
i don't think you can't take the exit d7
and yes of course the rook yeah did his
pawn strike these pawns are very strong
it's this one so so is
maybe i slightly prefer to be white here
unless black has some good move can
black play b4 be the way you want to
meet it this is what i was just thinking
just now i mean if if i play b4 then
i kind and if there's an exchange on b4
then i can just see a situation where
this one pawn on a6 or a5 is holding
back these two pawns and then you can
start to
you can kind of say well
that one porn has done a fantastic job
so therefore i will shift all my energy
into mobilizing my own poor majority on
the king side
yeah i mean this type of position here
would favor black in the same way you
have four pawns versus three and like
you said these two pawns bad as we just
saw if we just jump over to the pawn
structure in the other game this one
here where you have four verses
free and these two pawns have a great
chance to cause issues now i think we
have to go to
same let's head back and check up on
what's happening because
wow it was uh really exciting when we
left it we
sacrificed
and now knights whip two played and here
another move
that opens things up g5 this is this is
phenomenal stuff from
such energetic play from sam it is yeah
he's literally sacrificed a piece but
all of black's people all the blacks
guys they're energized yeah yeah they're
energized they're they're playing with
so much potential and uh
you can see that yeah
we might all have to buy his course
after this game he's looking very
confident uh there as well
i was going to say that yeah i mean it's
it's it's
looking brilliant and i'm just uh
look at the
like we don't use engines at all but all
we can see is the slider and the slider
is like in black
so let's work out what happens after
pawn takes just say i get greedy and my
pawn takes pawn
well i'm assuming i will keep the energy
going and take whenever two but i
haven't worked this out um okay so let's
try it because let's try it take several
things too it looks very natural rook
takes work um
so now
simple move is bishop takes f2 but you
should probably also consider
consider
other possibilities as well but bishop
takes f2 is key bishop takes f2 and you
just i mean you're already you're not
even material down right you're not and
if queen takes f2 this bishop's then
dropping
and you can see that white has a really
disgusting position all his piece is
kind of separated bishop on b7 will win
the game um in this one
there might be something better it might
be the same better yeah
i mean brook takes step two again this
is this is one of those positions where
look if you're going into a sharp stuff
like this with white or black
it's less about general principles and
more about actually memorizing knowing
the computer lines
yeah and a lot of games are now won
nowadays by knowing your theory very
well
um which i think sam sam is doing here
he's bringing out his uh
big novelties or maybe they've been
played before i'm not even sure
um
so rook f2 looks natural
and now after rook takes f2 is there
anything else that sam
can try here because you've got knight
e3 as well knight e3 trying to
do something like this bishop takes e3
bishop takes
this kind of move is is is uh
something to consider so okay so we have
some more moves rook takes f2 rook takes
off two and he's just gone bishop taking
f2 yeah
simple is good yeah simple is good
simple is not often the best isn't it
you don't really want to be playing
having to play like a 20
800.
so i like bishop takes f2 the material
has been recovered and uh
they do say that the secret ambition of
every gambiter to win back material
yeah or checkmate i'm not sure i don't
really care for them too just checkmate
the king you know yeah
[Music]
right i'd rather check than win my
material back well okay so okay right
right okay right simon so if you had a
choice
potential chance of checkmate
or win back your material and be okay
which one would you choose
depends how potential the chances
potential potential you know it's not
you can't say if i thought i had a very
if i if i thought i was favorite to
checkmate then um
because of course you know between
between winning back material or
checkmate we always choose checkmate
right but i mean if you you choose to
continue your attack and maybe it's
going to end and check mate but you know
who knows
i wasn't sure yeah i mean if i had if i
had definitely if i had a choice between
getting the material back retaining a
good position
or playing in a murky way that i wasn't
sure what's going to happen you'd always
win the material back yeah you're right
because you shouldn't risk it too much
but i mean you know that situation can
change on it i mean
if if if you're quite confident in your
attack then you know you've got a big
confidence as well space and by the way
we've been told that maybe the new move
here
was on move 26 knight to f2 maybe this
was the first new move but already by
the stage of anger it's looking very
very like fishy for for uh for white and
just catching up bishop d2 played
sam
it seems has a fantastic position can
korobot hold on by making exchanges with
rook to e1 something like this i think
that i think korobov has to try uh trust
has to try to eliminate some of the
major pieces like rookie one i like that
i i think
because you know the black king you know
white's king is in danger but so is
black king that king's not entirely out
of
the woods
so
i mean i think we can see we don't use
computers here to analysis obviously
this bar i do also find quite annoying i
have to say because it can judge your
thing but if we just look at the
position i think it's been very easy to
see if you have a good instinct
in this kind of position when sound did
sacrifice the piece look he's obviously
prepared it so we know it's good and if
you just look at the pieces on the board
look at look at black's pieces they're
all attacking you can tell straight away
good compensation you don't need to
really uh
even calculate so much
but like say you vancouver
if white can get some exchanges in they
might take a bit of heat off the
position
yeah um or perhaps he needs to do some
counter threats of his own
like rookie but i'm a little bit worried
that if i tried to go
okay so now i would be thinking about
rookie
rookie one
i think you have to go rookie well i
think i have to go through one right
because ricky two is happening
so rookie one is the only way to swap
some pieces off try to take some of
those pieces out of the position
and if you know if the brooks get
exchanged and everything like that then
it's going to be all right for white so
black
would have to think or something clever
here to keep that initiative going i
mean it might be maybe not even that
easy even if the rooks were off because
i mean this
there's a black is basically an extra
pawn in an end game
because uh
this g5 pawn
isn't as good as this pawn on c5 i mean
in games are all about like creating
past pawns and all checkmating but uh
yeah and i just see that's very easy for
black to go c5 c4 so like
i just
it's something that i have in the back
of my head
that an in-game isn't necessarily but
he's got he's gone into the ending he's
gone into the end game okay so now we're
gonna see
i mean it's not you know
this is kind of a risk-free way for sam
to play i don't know if there's anything
it's a bit disappointing when you seem
to have such a great initiative you go
into an ending i mean
i would have thought with white's knight
sort of having potential to come back
into the game this this this is a good
chance of white to hold i don't know if
it's uh you know it's
some chances at least i got rid of the
queens i don't know i don't know whether
you have great chances to hold because
i'm super quick i was just gonna say
with uh c4
just chopping this one through
yeah just push him yeah yeah
it is worrying porn it certainly needs a
big
porn big born that's working its way
shall we have a look at the um some
other games
yeah
this is very exciting let's go to um
here
yep so
we're around here and
chucky had just
castle king side and now very
interesting
wesley so picks a very aggressive plan
and the aggressive plan that wesley so
picks
is this castling queen side so
when you have castling opposite sides of
the board is gonna lead to a very
exciting tactical battle
knight d5 the knight is looking for some
squares knight f5
queen c5 and you have to watch out for
some sacrifices here so white just
secures that one and now black
sacrifices the pawn there maybe a pawn
is not so important
if you can get attacking chances but is
black to be able to generate
any attacking chances you know the
queen's come off you're a pawn down
where are blacks attacking chances to me
i don't think it's
enough for a pawn sacrifice this
um
because the white king is safe i mean
the only thing you can try is something
like rook takes
a two but then
knight takes f6 is is horrible because
you can't take the knight your rook
drops and if you take with a pawn your
king is
much more exposed than the white king
which can always block with bishop to b1
yeah um
so what is chucky's idea after knight to
e4 both players already losing time in
the position
um here
i would take white here ivanka would you
agree with that white spikes do not yeah
definitely i would take white um but it
does also at the same time remind me of
a caracan
like a mainline caracon where everything
has gone right for
black
but
i agree with everything you said though
and i am
white's pieces are just very well placed
it seems to be don't they and it is a
porn at the end of the day you know the
danger when you're a pawn up is you know
when there's a lot of peace on the board
maybe it doesn't matter but you've
always got it in the bank so you can
always welcome exchanges because any
ending you're a pawn up so it just gives
you that extra security and so should we
go to each board spend like 10 seconds
and we can try and do it quick yeah i
just had a quick quick look at some of
the games in the as azerbaijan against
poland match and it does look like it's
quite evenly balanced although in some
some games it does look like things are
swinging in poland's favor so
okay i team battle there because we have
two matches that we're trying to keep an
eye on yeah i can try to bring them up
but i don't know how easy that no no i
mean i i i think
poland at the minute have
have the edge but still everything's
playful
yeah
okay so this one wesley's so doing okay
now there is
everything
draw jeffrey versus kirill kirill's f6
works okay draw
good result with the black pieces of
hero he's playing very well
now
wesley i'm gonna put wesley down as a
win so one two thing this is just me
having a guess i'm not looking at the
computer bar this is uh we're going to
current positions
so the times are getting quick this one
whoa
i like black
black that's only because i like cheap
threats and you know i can see h3 coming
i'm thinking that looks a bit scary this
one could go either way
to be honest though i agree with you um
five is really strong
i don't know so i'm gonna say draw there
i'm just gonna put it up there i mean
i'm gonna say black
now surcover has got the slightly better
pawn structure a bit of pressure but
black's very solid here
yeah what would you say again i think
anna satonski is doing
more than okay
she's definitely a little bit better so
that one's it's very close we see shank
wins it has he managed to
see as i'm saying i mean the ball is
opposite kind of bishops and okay if you
can stop this pawn
and
now
you can always even try sacrificing at
some point we could see bishop and
knight versus king but a thing
[Music]
we get this position here where
of course there's this threat of the
pawn coming but there's a lot of
materials going so even if you do you
know somehow
there might be a way to re-sacrifice
material i don't know i mean this could
be a win for strengthening but i'm going
to go draw i'm going to say that qurapos
is going to hold this one what's your
right yeah i'm thinking that too i mean
i can
and also just one kind of point point
out and i don't know it's a long time
long way off in the future but black
does have the wrong rook pawn
yeah
so
that that's uh it's on the wrong collar
it's going to clean on a dark square so
and that's a long way away i can
understand but sometimes these small
things
give you hope
i mean there's some quite clear cut
lines okay so this one is just trying to
go knight f4 get a clear opposite color
of bishop ending if you can get those
knights yeah let's listen yeah this is
this is uh you know
okay the last game i think it's going to
be a draw every game very very uh very
tight and this one is
with b3 just being played here
um
[Music]
barely wait one second so what's what's
happening after
knight takes it if i were to take yeah
if i if i were to take
anything
so i have to take back
and now you take here and here
i go probably root d3 and i'm
and if i were to take the other way if i
were to take the bishop
so if i was going to take the bishop now
yep
okay
i'm going to go rookie four
and this is a better try because you
want to get your work behind the
passport yes but my king is coming quick
so i will go for example rook c1 brook
takes c4 and now rook c2
and i feel i should be fine here with
white because your rook can't move
without me taking pawns should be
interesting i can't play rook a4 but you
know you take from c3 i'll take this one
and
this position it is certainly a draw
technically
actually i think uh they say that white
has the better chances
yeah white yeah white does in these
things because you can get your rook
behind the pawn and then slowly push
these guys but of course it's a drawer
yeah uh so very really just a very close
match i mean do we even know who we
think has got the edge at the moment in
in this match no i mean i guess it's
going to double down to time so if we go
back to the wesley
game because um
and we had bishop g4
rook c8 queen e5 knight takes e4
and it's getting quite tactical knight
c5 here um
and
chucky is down on time down on time as
well
uh in this position
um
with
knight c5 playing so remember wesley so
a porn up here
um
but it's always a bit messy when there's
opposite side castling yeah exactly so i
just wanted to point out if white were
very careless and i'm sure wesley will
not be
so careless but i um if you just made
them random move like h3 or something
like that some
then you have knight takes bishop check
and this would just win this one yeah
it's probably even better yeah
we haven't enough results
another result another draw so we have
two but we haven't we have a decisive
result right
no um that's a different match
which we're not really have much time to
look at at the moment we're trying to
look at those
so basically the decisive result that i
was talking about is that duda
has oh he's been in mama jar off great
results dude with black
with black pieces so far
off yeah
so poland are going in the lead in that
six game match poland versus azerbaijan
and mama jaroff is incredibly brilliant
player but duda has beaten him has been
a draw there so it's one and a half half
out of six
in in that game two draws in the
american match
um let's go back to
let's go back to see if sam is actually
making any progress he's gone c2 forcing
bishop d2 the only way to save that pawn
knight b4 and he's got this idea knight
f4 check
king f5 g4 check king e4
and
it's getting very tactical
it's always been tactical
i mean i say getting tactical it's just
the tactical mess here
yeah
i mean so what happens if you
oh we have a result we have a result wow
they said it quick this end be quick it
actually
it's only very quick
america have gone one up usa gone one up
after did he didn't blunder the way he
said really knight c5
rook
no no no no i didn't think so rig d5
i just wanted to point out this out that
uh queen d4 but this this is
now
bishop e6
but he's just played rick g richie fight
know how rookie five five
yeah
he's quite known for running out of time
but
you i mean you have to probably play g6
here that's the only way to stop mates
and just hope your
chances here really cost ukraine it's
being flagged
still a very complex position and the
yeah eventually this has happened to him
and the candidates in london when he was
trying to qualify for the world
championships he ran out of time in like
three four games it was it's really
exceptional
so
america one up we're free to go yeah one
up with three games to go if sam can win
then it will guarantee at least a draw
in the match but what about this one
which we thought was heading towards a
draw is it going to be a draw more
exchanges it actually went the way we
said
and
i would imagine
that this
is now well
i don't know
well yeah this is this this is a really
this has gone quite badly wrong for
white white white i don't think i think
king d3 is is an error because
you leave f2 on pre
and but otherwise i mean the problem is
is that black was going to go king to c6
i think yeah yeah i mean i want to need
to go rook c2 and can then king do three
a bit slowly
because now
is a bit tasty yeah
because here but even so perhaps you
should have played rook c2 as opposed to
taking the pawn
yeah rook c2 here is not so bad i mean
uh
but then we're okay
it's a problem yeah
which makes makes it a bit more
complicated so
yeah so brilliant play from annie
who's given herself some winning chances
in what looked like a drawn position
and let's again the times getting so
short we should get up to the current
situation and
with these two past pawns against white
zero passports and an extra pawn this
this is looking very good for america
now america i think you're gonna win the
first leg um in the
poland azerbaijan match we've had two
more draws and we've had results yes and
their results azerbaijan have drawn
level
so yeah it's all leveled that one on the
bottom board let's have a look at the
two games remaining in the azerbaijan
match this is a big one rather versus
ralph mandersoff
and at the moment radislav is the
exchange up
and he's grabbing pawns here so
um it looks like poland have good
chances to win this one and the other
game
is key and it does also like look like
poland you're doing well there the peace
up yeah
yep okay so that's it so poland will be
winning their game against azerbaijan
which
is a little bit unexpected actually
yeah i think they've now won as long as
in this game black doesn't win uh and
black is getting the worst of it here
lots of pieces being swapped off so so
it does look like poland are are doing
well back to the very well yes they have
guaranteed a draw at least so um
and now well america are taking charge
of all of all the games here um this one
was looking
um very messy but all of a sudden white
has won a rook somewhere let's see if we
can find out where
and
it looked okay for black but look okay
yeah
white starts to use those rooks come
into the position and it's good
they've won this this leg
so
and can shanklin win let's have a look
here well i'm i'm it was it was getting
very murky
and we looked at this as the last
position
and
now shankling wins a piece but
this pawn
seems to be coming through
and
and it does come through forcing
shankling to give back the piece and now
if anything it's white
who has some chances but well i'm not
sure because um
because shangri-la is going for the
april
and uh
yeah it's just i mean it's it should be
a draw but if anyone it should be it
should be a draw yeah second nine knight
c6
white white
i mean not for long
but you could try this
can we have a look at the um
the
the remaining game from the azerbaijan
poland match okay so that's a draw and
so
usa have won the first leg so let's have
a look at um
void to check
against marmodof okay so it does look
like that game is going to finish
yep and and uh voice check what so
poland have also won again
the first leg
um is this one of the guys is is this
wesley so is he getting uh i think
wesley slows playing a bit of bullet
chest in between rounds is that right or
is this the second game
no this is the second game i think it's
just
so wesley so he's playing the olympiad
he's just beating the round chick and he
decides to have a quick game of bullets
just the way he's probably just to
yeah
but it reminds me of that time i thought
in gibraltar i think where um ivan lost
very quickly to sandy pan
and
after like ivan chuck wasn't interested
in analyzing the game he just wanted to
play some bullet games against uh sandy
pan just to kind of
prove something or just relieve his
tension
so this is the last game remaining
uh and a couple of things are clear so
just to let you know what's happened
it's all quick it's all fast you have to
keep your eyes on the screen as well as
we do just if you blink something
happens that's how quick it is when
we're doing 12 wars but
america usa have defeated
one of the real strong teams ukraine who
beat china in the first leg so america
just needs to draw or win the next leg
and they're through to the semi-final
ukraine needs to fight back
in the match between poland and
azerbaijan
poland won that leg so they're also
going to be um favorites at the moment
azerbaijan needs to come back with a win
and this is the last game
remaining of of the round
yeah but i think it's a i think it's an
easy oh i was going to say it was an
easy win after e4
but okay i i think it is still
a very easy win because this is you
forget about this a3 pawn you just
concentrate on pushing the e4 pawn e5
pawn
very easy when yeah at that point that
pawn's coming you can just support it
with your king
king
very easy this king can't help the pawn
no i mean
so it's very easy just bang bang bang
bang just keep marching it up and then
the rook will come and abandon the a3 at
the right time and then just create some
shield for the some cover for the king
so it's actually i mean it looked for it
was a very close match at the start but
if we actually look at the scores and
how it develops
then america really took they really
took control uh usa came through took
trial at the end of the game and
all their players in equal position
they're all pushed and they all just did
what they needed to do so
very convincing in the end very
convincing from america against a very
good team
um
and okay we can see that annie
i'm sure is pretty confident in the in
the camera there she that she's going to
win
and this is quite an easy win
you can even do the old bridging
maneuver
which black might do bring the king up
yeah i think it's just going to go rook
to d4 or f4
yeah
or if you
or if you want yeah okay she's gonna
she's gonna go for
king f2
easy one yeah okay and i think we're
gonna see
white give up
this is one of those ones you all should
learn even without this pawn imagine
that's not on the board how do you win
this
well you bridge with the rook at the
right moment to stop the checks and then
your pawn will come down
uh that is the last game so um
well very very exciting
um the second round will be coming up at
some point
reasonably soon
on the hour um yeah but it was a very
comfortable performance by the usa i
mean despite what we thought that might
be close match in fact i thought maybe
ukraine would uh would be favorites
actually because uh chefchenko was
playing so well and of course a team
with uh with uh ivan churk and korobov
osmack strong strong women players
i i really thought it would be much
closer than it was but yeah
as we saw in the previous game previous
match between russia and hungary
anything is possible
that's right so
we're going to be back about 10 minutes
um it's going to be fascinating can
ukraine
do a charge can they get it to
armageddon i think we're going to see an
armageddon somewhere i think so too i
mean also the question is there are two
matches going on we mustn't forget that
there's also poland playing against
azerbaijan and poland have beaten uh
azerbaijan azerbaijan also in a comeback
situation um yeah can they pull it off i
think so shortly i think this we've got
good good chances for armageddon here
so be back in 10 minutes and stay with
us uh we'll see what happens it's all
going to be quick fast playoff we think
it's going to be an armageddon don't be
evan cause somewhere
somewhere will it be maybe two
armageddons and it's going to be
brilliant
okay we're see you soon
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
welcome back to
the last big match of the quarter finals
or the last two big matches
we have a lot of excitement going on
it's fast-paced it's quick
and it's one of the most important chess
tournaments
not online but the whole couple of years
the on the line at chess olympiad
normally taken place in person about 150
teams were playing at the start of this
and now it's getting down to the last
couple of the last four teams uh this is
the quarterfinals we're gonna have
america playing against um
let me get this right ukraine
and america took the first leg so
ukraine have to win this one to get
armageddon
and poland's going ahead against
azerbaijan so azerbaijan have to fight
back to get armageddon there
uh just a quick kind of mention just a
quick reminder that it's actually match
points that matter not game points so it
doesn't matter if uh azerbaijan
or or um
ukraine wins six nil it will still be
armageddon game points are irrelevant
it's just the match points
that's right it doesn't matter at all
america
the match the ukraine america match it
started off looking really close
uh could have gone either way but then
all of a sudden america when
and actually the one game
we thought might end the soonest sam
sam's game who showed brilliance opening
preparation actually ended in the draw
uh which was a bit peculiar
now
ukraine needs to keep some substitutions
one of the great things about this is
that you're not obliged to play with the
team that you put that you put in for
the first round first leg
so
just looking at the pairings ukraine
have made some substitution as have
america so the big substitution is that
ivan chuck will not be playing on top
board
okay
it will be anton korobov
and then simon on board two i'm going to
let you pronounce
vengeance
[Music]
his surname i'm very sorry
he's now playing against sam shanklin
uh for america the big substitution is
that uh abraha tatev arab hamiyam has
stepped in for cursor yip
okay and we can see that they're
actually they actually start to kick off
now already um which is
you know they're in with the fight
and korobov
big challenge for him here were the
white pieces and they need to win the
match and uh
he's gone he's gone for this e3 stuff
again which
he's this has given him a second white
which is interesting he had this against
sam shanklin shanklin showed brilliant
preparation
it depends what he plays now but
if he goes c4 it goes back into more
normal waters but
if you play like b3 which is one of my
preferred ways of playing actually you
get
the so-called collie system and i i
think against someone like wesley so so
you know so well prepared you see what i
did there they're playing something like
b3 i don't normally do that i didn't
mean to just realized i'm so clever i'm
so brilliant um that b3 bishop b2 is
quite i think this is quite a cool
system to play um with the knight coming
to e5 i hope he goes for for something
like that
though it's a bit quiet in a must-win
situation
it can be quiet but i i think i think it
actually gives you and he's gone for it
good this is the zooka collie system i
mean
people think it's quite about i don't i
think it's actually very aggressive
because you get to play f4 you get to
put your knight here
and often you go for this king side
attack so i don't know it's it's it's
got a brilliant game in this in the
british championships didn't you beat
ravi harrier i yeah i used it to beat
ravi harrier and it's another opening
that you support plays a lot and
it's i just think it gets out of the
theory korribos is a very natural player
we saw what happened when he went into
deep fury in the last ground he got in a
lot of trouble
so he's kind of saying no these
americans they know they know too much
theory just just give me something where
i can play some chess
um i think it's wise i think it's wise
against wednesday's but do you think
it's wise against wesley so because i
mean
you do have traditional antidotes to
these type of systems um
you do and there's lots of ways where
black can probably equalize
but
i think wesley's so
awesome player very well prepared you
play something that he hasn't got as
much experience in you get him out of
maybe his normal kind of positions
and you can keep all the pieces on the
board in this line there's no early
exchanges
so you keep the tension and you give
yourself chances for a long time i think
it's a very good decision personally
from the corridors
so we go down to um
sam shankland against uh stem
okay you have to remember actually that
america just need a draw to coast
through to the semi-finals
in days and
in this one sam with the white pieces
faces um well the the perk the modern
system
but he goes now into a d4 setup
and after bishop g7 knight to c3
he's offering the king's indian defense
but black plays e5
and
this is normally met by pawn takes e5
going for an ending but sam
does this anyway just after a couple of
moves
gets the queens off the board and plays
bishop to e3 bishop to g4
bit calm at this game and last one you
rank here the last one that sam played
was all over the shop this is yeah that
was spectacular with peace sacrifices
potential attacks and then suddenly this
massively complicated ending so yeah
definitely quieter
um okay i i like uh i like sam's
position you know i'm i'm always a big
fan of
of putting a knight onto d5
and of course having this nice
lead in development so you know
invisibility to castle as well
yeah i mean black's moved the king a
couple of times uh it's doing a little
bit of yo-yoing in the middle of the
board
the bishop on g7 is not very well
positioned because it's looking at its
own pawn there
the one advantage black has in this
position
if he can get himself coordinated is the
d4 square
white would probably i would if i was
white rather had my pawn back on c2
because at some point if black gets the
knight into d4 you can't chase it away
with either c3 or e3 a pawn move both
your pawns have gone too far
so this is black's kind of positional
hope to
secure a knight into the center of the
board
now next game i think we should go to
yeah
oh i like this one i don't know if it's
the next game but i like it it's oh it's
a dragon i like a bit of dragon action
and
we have well this is okay new player
tatia um
and i don't know if uh
gaffianco was playing in the first one i
don't think so but no she didn't play
the first one but she did play in the
match against china where she did
she had who you found on the ropes with
some great opening preparation
um yeah this is going to be exciting
game because actually both players are
renowned for their very direct and
aggressive style
and this is the dragon variation um
which we see black adopt it is supposed
to actually not be based on what a
dragon looks like but on a star
consolation i heard don't know if that's
true or not but
wow like to see patterns and everything
you know
we
we can find a name for absolutely
everything
we'll call that we'll call that
something
it's true and i think this is why a lot
of chess players are successful in other
areas of life like in england a lot of
them became stock brokers made millions
because they started to see patterns in
other areas um i don't think if you're a
chess player you're necessarily clever
um i don't think that goes you know
look at me but it can you can actually
see patterns elsewhere
we see a typical pawn sacrifice here h5
and this is to open up the h5
and now
castles and there's just this brutal
idea of checkmating black along the
h-file
black goes knight e5 black's not gonna
let white have all the fun and this is
the typical counter sacrifice
that
black gets ready black often wants to
like just take that knight
destroy some of the white position and
get on with it really exciting
it is super exciting but the funny thing
is judging by the clock times i would
have said that you know
judging from the position i would have
said okay fine white's got her
preparation in but it's actually black
who's got the preparation and she's got
more time than she when she started
so um yeah
it's true yeah and
you know it's this is one position by
the way i mean i've had i played this a
lot and you shouldn't take your queen
here
taking with the queen is a big mistake
because of rook takes c3 a lot of people
do this
but you should take the rook because if
you go queen takes it looks really scary
for black it does look very scary simon
but black just goes rook takes here
queen takes here threatening queen a1
check and queen takes knight for example
if you go g5 this is like some tactic
you have to watch out for winning a
piece and this this kind of position
here the black queen starts getting all
this counter play and black is doing
very well so
um you you should really take the rook
keeping the knight under control the
reason i know a lot about the dragon is
because when you're a kid you're trying
to learn an opening and obviously tatty
a very strong player knows this you kind
of pick the opening with the coolest
name
the dragon you can't get a caller name
the dragon it's not like there's a lot
of weird names out there that berlin is
normal name i mean what's the weirdest
name like speckled egg
no the weirdest name has to be the
monkey bum
the monkey's bun that's a good one yeah
the monkey's bum yeah or the fried liver
is pretty freaky
the orangutan
any opening named after animal is
rubbish is the rule i hear that's what
that's what i've heard anyway um
we see this typical sacrifice
immediately um from gapanenko so they're
going for it they're going for it and
this this is not as strong as before
because the queen's come off
but the point of black's play blank has
a very solid pawn formation and after
rook c8
black can play positioning against them
but just look at the clock times i mean
it's very rare that you see a player
have more time than when they started
someone just reminded me that the
dragon's actually an animal and uh
that's why i don't play anymore because
it's exactly but you said very clearly
any opening named after
he's dodgy an animal
not good
that's not good okay we move on this is
i mean obviously i'm fascinated by this
because i play it myself or used to
loads of fun but there's other games
and
this one is white plain like carlson i
can see already this is a london system
and ozmak against anna and
carlson has played many games like this
if you look at him online and he puts
his knight here he tries to control the
dark squares
um
now these positions i think very
slightly better for white because you've
got the central control and you can try
to start some attack you've got a little
bit of e-file black's very solid this is
just one black is black is very solid
but i mean one one thing i just have to
say about the black position is that
normally white wants to get this kind of
this kind of situation where you have uh
a strong knight on e5 and black has a
bad bishop on c8 e7 and uh that light
square bishop is gone
yep this is this definitely helps
black's position
yeah so that helps black and uh
yeah
so i mean i mean we'll have to wait and
see this one i think it's early days um
and nothing seriously bad there
now
going back to this one with the wesley
so game where i was quite impressed by
um
the opening choice by korribov let's see
how it's developed
and this is the normal plan that white
plays where you can follow up with f4 if
you want to go super aggressive i mean
the club player's way of playing as i
say club players is that after knight
bd7 you literally just go f4 you put
your rook on h3 and you check mate on h7
it's so easy you know for example i'm
just going to put it on the board black
starts pushing over here black goes
woohoo
and then you and then you sort of well
you don't actually take there now you
get rid of this one first
and then you take here and then you go
here i've won loads of games like this
and then
happy days then the score sheets
but the one problem with playing f4 two
too quickly and the one move to watch
out for you lose control of e4 and i'm
sure wesley would have played knight e4
here
and this blocks that idea
hence why queen e2 is being played rook
ca and a more positional idea but he
does go for it you anchor queen c7 f4
i like it it's like a dutch ivanka
we all know what i think of the dutch
funky stuff
g6
and this is
blocking the diagonal but here come the
boys knight on g to f3 they're coming
this way
he sees the king he kills the king
pawn takes d4 pawn takes d4 and the
knight doesn't come into the score yeah
i mean
yeah
so
um and this is this is the move you play
you get the knight here and you get that
central control and you can even support
it with f5
and
[Music]
black should be all right yeah black
should be out and as far as i know if
you get a knight to e4 that is the
antidote to like the london system the
police socket and yeah
all these things yeah this is always a
good idea
interesting way that white's playing
though because he's got slightly nicer
pawn structure maybe he can put his
knight on e3 which should be a nice
little nice little square for it so it's
the position you can play yeah
definitely there's lots of play left and
uh yeah
so can we check out the game against
jeffrey um
jeffrey
i'm trying to find that game let's just
see
one down
i think two
there again
there we go
berlin has occurred here so jeffrey jean
playing very solidly can tell straight
away it's berlin with
this very solid opening jeffrey shong
appreciates how strong kirill is and
not playing any risky openings
um
[Music]
i mean the berlin
if
what you say
white's got a slightly better pawn
structure
because of the double pawns
black has the two bishops which can be
good later on
in this case white seems to put his
pieces on very sensible squares but
black extremely solid
yeah black is black is very solid i mean
the king has found itself on b7
which i think is a kind of like a an
aggressive way how to handle
the berlin
um because usually the king is
stuck in the center but uh yeah let's
put in
early days for this one this is the two
i mean it's very it is incredibly early
days
um now i think we have a couple of the
games of the poland match we're trying
to update you on the scores there as we
go on unfortunately
uh i don't we're going to concentrate on
america uh as the timing is so the big
thing that that's happened in the
azerbaijan is that rajabov is playing
that mahmoud is not playing and he's
been replaced by rajapov
okay i'll see if i can get some links to
the games there as we go on
um
but for now
we're concentrating on the american the
match with the usa uh okay we have this
game here the poland game all a bit
early days
which board you want to look at in the
american match usa
um let's check out
the bottom board uh the girls under 20.
which is
we've got so many games up now we're
trying to the one that's underneath i
think underneath jeffrey's
and this one ah no no that's okay that's
uh here we go yes this is what we have
later
um okay
and well lots of things being changed
off here you anchor already um is anyone
better here
well
i um
do you have to bear in mind that
ukraine need to win this match
they you know
and they play and there's a very solid
start so far i mean i haven't seen any
promising
positions but okay it's still early days
things can go wrong
i mean this this game doesn't look so
exciting it must be even um
they've got you know the three versus
two but then white's got the majority
over here it is it's an even position
i mean i can just see a mass trade
happening with bishop takes knights and
then
bishop bishop and then
and then the rook coming to to d8
yeah yeah it doesn't really matter which
one and then
king coming into e7 and uh
some big trade
indeed
um we did see annie
grind down
her opponent very mature performance
from someone so young in the last round
of this
she got into an ending and she she won a
very nice ending from what should have
been an equal position so she's clearly
very comfortable in in this type of
position but at the moment
this is not too much to report here
maybe we can just do an update again so
we can see if ukraine have a chance of
bringing it to armageddon so
um this one we go for a draw remember
it's a six board match
this one we're going to say draw i think
as well
yeah
so two draws out of six
now this one between korabov and wesley
so
again it's finely balanced so i'm going
to go for three draws out of six so far
it's a lot of draws this one is also not
much happening i mean it will heat up
this is what happens i don't know i
quite like i uh i mean
it's it's to be honest i'm not really
sure because i can see something black
will be playing for play um c
c5 c4 and then
and then playing some kind of b5 and b4
and then
try to get something out in the the
queen side because
does white have a threat on the on the
king side
i think it's yeah i mean i think this is
probably quite risky because white will
eventually
play like f3 and start going g4 g you
know play effect five and
you know black's gonna get the queen
side play but when white arranges to
move f5 white will generally get some
attack on the king's side
but we're still away from doing that
we're a long way from doing it at the
moment and
i mean it seems fairly even though i
mean it's again very early to say you
you take black here i'd probably take
white i mean i i like i like going for
the king's side rather than the queen
side even if it's a bit dubious so it's
probably personal preference but
uh in the balance so far
and so there's not much going on i mean
the the exciting i suppose most exciting
one was this dragon
uh when let's have let's
let's have a look on that one
we got this typical dragon like they say
ending
and this is a move to bring the knight
around
g5
important here not to allow rook h1 and
rook takes h7 you have to block that up
with knight to h5
and now the rook comes here anyway
[Music]
with the following position
is
white if white can get rid of this
knight it's going to be
disastrous
for black rook takes h7 coming but
not easy to do
it looks
i mean i suppose one of the points of
this move is if black now
continues with a plan that started with
bishop to e8
which is to try to bring the knight
around this way
it looks good in the center it probably
should remain in center but one idea is
to try and take over here
all of a sudden black takes the pressure
off this pawn so maybe white can go
knight e2
knight c5 and now
played knight to f4
and this is like a weird little tactic
because the knights lost control of this
pawn and the point is if you take here
it's of course going to be
yeah check mates
just to update you simon there's been
one result actually in the poland
azerbaijan match and that is that uh
a sadly he beat uh simon gumalats um
this was on the junior board
okay great so
he did it with the black pieces so this
is a very very important victory
remember azerbaijan need to win in order
to take the match to armageddon
yeah they do azerbaijan if they win it
goes to armageddon and of course if
ukraine win it goes to armageddon that
armageddon really exciting they pick a
random board out of the six boards
and that random board plays off four
minutes versus five
and winner takes all uh so really
exciting
it's it's fantastic because uh you know
it's like a category you take a category
or you see either the woman uh a man or
a junior or do a girl junior so
yeah
okay i'm going to try to now get all the
games up so let me know if this
particular game you want to go to your
anchor as well
and i will just try to get everything
arranged so actually we've got the
rajaboth game now and this is this is a
real big game duda
has he's a real real hero he's
he's performed so well for poland i
think it's something like eight out of
nine or nine out of ten he's got
rajabov though is
a legend
um he's been around longer than duda
he's achieved a lot
he should have been playing in the
candidates but he turned his place down
um and there's a lot of controversial
that in the end because he turned it
down due to the kobe crisis he proved to
be correct with his decision but
then mvl was in and mdl deservedly uh
can't be taken out because he's leading
the candidate so it's all a bit weird
but rajaboff very strong player we're in
this position now after
c4 um
the c pawn looking quite threatening
but white has his own trumps
with a nice square potentially on d5
supported by the pawn open file etc
about equal ivanka about equal i would
say um
yeah i mean it's a state the obvious it
kind of hinges on this the c4 pawn
whether it's a big strength or a
or a weakness at the minute it's looking
like a big strength isn't it because
this bishop on c1 is just not good and
this rook i really like this rook on b3
it's real
i mean i can see that's why white's
played knight e6 in order to try to play
knight to d4 and just chase that rook
away
and
we have another exchange of pieces here
we have another india yeah
yeah but you know
i think this could be simplified very
quickly
uh as well i mean you could have white
i mean if white wanted to
i mean i i think i'd take white here for
anyone somehow but
if for example i go to
yes that's my intention i want to go c3
so i want to just take here get the
pawns off
but you go c3
so c3 and then now you're gonna have to
probably i mean because you've got
knight a4 as well if i go bishop d4
attacking this one knight a4
and i'm a little bit scared as white
here because
yeah you're taking that one i mean i can
maybe come around here but i'm getting
myself in all sorts of pins
yeah exactly you've got things like
knight b2 check so i mean
this hasn't happened has it no okay so
dc1 has been played
and i'm guessing
this move c3 because i mean if if rajab
wants to play on of course he could go
just go rogue takes a three and i think
the game i think the players will see
degree draw
yeah this is a move to shake hands after
bishop takes beast oh they've agreed to
draw anything they've agreed to draw
okay yeah
so when do i see three
you know maybe it was because of bishop
d
but bishop d4 i can just go rotate a3 so
it's actually bishop takes knight you
have to take the pawn and now i just go
a4 and i'm going to come around here and
it's going to be into the game it's
going to finish the draw
but okay
remember azerbaijan need to win
yeah okay sam shanklin who played that
very interesting
game in round one
and
things were heating up we saw we got
roughly to this position
um
black
is a little bit passive with his king
his king's like wandered around like
some drunk fool on the back right there
where am i going to go
and
sam has
managed to activate his pieces very well
the d4 square now under black's control
but
he's able to play f4 opening the
position up before
black can centralize
knight e6
and
we have a little tactical sequence here
whoa this is looking very dangerous of
black
yeah
yeah i mean wow we're looking at a a
white victory i think
yeah definitely i mean bishop h because
there's no great discovered check is
there no
i mean this this is looking a bit scary
for white but wherever you move the
knight so what
yeah and i also have the threat just i
mean i also have the threat of playing
rook h7
with the idea of going rook h
eight yeah come down here and uh
skewering the king of rook yeah
the problem is suvanka i think sam
played just really well opening up
because black's never been able to get
his drunk king you know back to bed he's
he's fallen asleep outside i mean i
think usa are going to win here are
going to win this particular game is
great great and look at the time
difference as well sam shanklin has
eight and a half minutes to uh 38
seconds
yeah it's true
this pawn so scary i mean it's just it's
just one square away from disaster and
sam is now going to win a pawn back
and then use the z pawn to convert the
game completely correct this is going to
be a victory for america so
they're doing very well so far usa
pushing ukraine and ukraine
not answering not looking like they're
winning on any boards at the moment no
we can
have a quick look at the another
um game between two
superb players two top players in the
world but this is the poland versus as
by john marshall remember azerbaijan
need to win to get into the uh
armageddon stage
typical position black has a nice
control of d5 square
but white has two bishops and white can
eventually try to start some kind of
attack against the king
i was looking at this position just now
i was thinking this looks like a caracan
and then i then i just had a look yeah
it is from a caracon you know and then
i
i think black is doing
quite well because some of the one of
the things about this position is that
white really wants to generate a
kingside attack with
it all depends on whether white can get
g2 g4
yeah
so if white gets that then the position
is very very dangerous the only thing i
would say is that it's actually not
ideal to have a knight on d5
you want the rook to be down that square
so
because the knight looks pretty on d5
but it hasn't isn't actually doing so
much um but uh the fact that the white's
gone a3 means that there's a nice little
hook on b4 to open up open up the
position so i can see a a5 a4 and then
b4
so i'm liking black's position
quite a bit actually
okay yeah i mean i'm i i
i can see that with a4 and b4 i mean
again opposite side castling is probably
who's going to open up the opposing
quick king the quickest and
this break with g4 takes one move you
have to go f3
two moves you have to get the knight out
of the way
and then you have to get out of the way
i'm not sure whether you even need to do
you can even sacrifice the pawn like if
you were to go g4 and force black to go
h takes g4 then
you should do it you shouldn't wait
until
if knight takes yeah not okay unless i'm
saying if you have to if you if black is
forced to get pawn takes then simply
just sacrifice the corn don't be afraid
of that
okay now bishop here has been played now
one thing you have to also be careful of
your bank in this position you suddenly
lost control of b3 and b4 b3 is a
standard sacrifice idea i mean let's
just show it
against b4 white what would certainly
want to keep that error the ball closed
if he takes it
it's very good for black black is going
to come down the a file so the way you
defend oh dear what have i done
the way you defend against this is by
trying to keep it blocked
one more move you'll block it up again
but then this is be free like sacrifice
and if you take it rook b8 and i don't
know if it's working here but this
this would scare me a little bit if i
was white i would scare me too i mean
this is definitely things that i would
think about doing um the only thing i
would say is that as white i wouldn't be
looking at going bishop takes b3 i would
be looking at trying to keep that uh
that line closed
but uh i just with right is just so slow
you know white needs to get rid of that
this knight on g
on g3 and i mean i i think perhaps needs
to go 94 or something
we do have one more move i mean after um
waiter check didn't like this idea of
sacrificing the poor a bit more of a
classical player he didn't feel the need
he's actually gone knight h7 oh and this
is quite interesting because after
bishop h6 i mean he he's
he's given up the exchange i mean this
is always something that white could
have done but
in these type of positions it's not even
clear when the exchange is going to help
much because you're opening things up
but white's got knight e4
and now the white piece is a sort of
sort of causing something
they're coming back in i don't like this
knight h7 move at all
i've to me step in the wrong direction
yeah it does it looks weird to put the
knight over here i agree
now we should say sam shankling has won
well done sam two very good games he's
played he didn't quite manage to win the
first game but look at this amusing
final position
um this is this is the final position
the poor king
the poor king was totally
mindless and it ends up in an even more
mindless situation
all you need to do now is put make a
knight here and then go knight c7
you get a double mate yeah can i just do
that for fun so i'm not i'd oh i've got
auto queen no you've got auto queen
simon oh no what have i done there don't
do that
oh no
what have i done you're in focus mode
you need to hit that button little
button on the yeah
okay
so we go here and then all of a sudden
black goes oh i'm i'm okay i'm gonna go
a5 and then you go here and you're like
okay so let's have a look at let's take
a look quick look at the other games and
see how the situation is playing out
sure this remember ukraine have to win
and they're one down at the moment and
how is korabov getting on so
it was around about this position
um
and
now
let's see wesley so
is
grabbing a pawn he's gonna pawn up
i think if if if korobov loses this game
it's
really bad news really bad
all right so is it is there any chance
for
e4 okay so now e3 is coming
so you have to block that uh pawn
yeah it's a queenie free can't allow
that pawn to the queen
and now a little tactic event could just
bishop take c5 and nice
it looks ugly for white everything's
kind of hanging now
rook b1
bishop e7
bishop b4
[Music]
time situation they're both a little bit
short
current position rook c8
wesley is has an overwhelming position
he does overwhelming the queen's now
come in he's also material up uh on top
of everything else so
there's a lot of bad things going on so
uh
okay this is good news for us fans
okay so let's have a look at uh
let's have a look at the game with anna
satonski because okay okay
so i'm just trying to find it yeah
yeah this one here okay yes and
i'll go through the moves again because
i think it might be interesting people
see
quickly how things have developed and
night before
the night oh okay okay
okay so this means
okay so this means that
if wesley so
wins
yes
is that is this a decisive no that has
to mean that i have two and a half
points
not quite not quite yet i mean yes
wesley so let's have a look wesley is
doing very well here
um now
the game between kirill
and jeffrey is still still actually
going on
so this is the kind of one where kirill
is going to really have to win with
white
i'm not sure where ukraine are getting
any of their victories from on any of
the boards america actually even in the
last match didn't like they're in any
danger of losing any of the games
they've been very solid very
professional
in their approach is this a potential
danger this ending
with the h
it could be
time situation not looking too too
healthy for kira
at the
moment i mean black is a porn up
um
so black could play e5 and try to hold
on to the extra pawn but
again like ivanka said it's not always
the quantity it's the quality
and
this pawn here
could now be supported with something
like rook h1 and it's very hard for
black to stop that pawn um
there's not really any past pawns
at the moment that white has to worry
about
if you end up blocking it then the king
is going to come to g6 as well so
exactly yeah
to my eyes
it does seem
that well just look at the time uh
it's actually equal in material now
because he's got this pawn back
jeffrey's decided you can have that pawn
because i need to try and get my rook
behind and uh he is allowing
very interesting after rook h1 though
yeah now it's a race
he's relying on harry harry is just like
all or nothing harry yeah you're either
a hero or you're not and he's just gonna
go harry come on all the way forward
okay so
push it
real good
i think ukraine have serious chances to
win here i totally agree and
it's this pawn black's probably going to
have to give this rook up for the pawn
um so is he going to be able to get
his own pawns creating some havoc in the
meantime the only way you're going to
stop this pawn i mean i don't think the
king is going to get there in time is it
h let's say you go
h5 king here h6 king here h7 no it's not
so that's a strange move where's he
going with the king
maybe he just wants to support the rook
so now okay
he's got to stop the white king coming
forwards i see
and he's going to bring the rook back to
g8 now
yeah
this is the only move otherwise harry
does queen
now the king can come back yeah i mean i
go age seven and i bring the king back
very seriously
but hang on a second how how
yeah because you have to use a temper to
get to
you know you have some very serious
winning chances yeah i mean he's
checking again
oh perhaps this is the idea this is
sneaky then you just simply keep
checking and force the king to go to h
five i could go to g3 yeah if i need to
yeah but if you go to clean g3 then you
go rook rook f8 and you bring your king
around
my king around in time yeah well very
nice defensive idea and
we have another result by the way and um
we'll come back to this one the other
result is black has won so this is given
ukrainian glimmer chance
ukraine have got their first victory in
this dragon the dragon is victorious
let's have a look very quickly at the
end of this game this is where black
sacrificed the exchange in very typical
fashion
and
it looks reasonably balanced but the
black knight is starting to have a lot
of fun here
in the structure and blacks this is the
kind of thing you often get in the
dragon black's pawns so compact easy to
defend and they start marching up the
board exactly what they're doing now
uh this gives this gives the ukraine a
little bit of chance does it ivanka for
this victory certainly
so we'll show the end and that is a nice
way to finish well done
uh wesley so on the other hand there's
one with the black pieces that's a big
blow
so currently
i think i'm right you've encouraged
saying
america are one up
with
not that game
uh this is a draw okay okay now that is
probably enough for america isn't it
they didn't this clever idea of getting
the draw yeah i was wondering why he
didn't try king h5 but i think i guess
that's because king f6 what a what a
ingenious way of securing the draw
because it did look like white like was
in trouble
yeah this is he had to try something but
i think i think jeffrey has done a great
job of defending there so i think now
that means america in the semi-finals
let's just let's guarantee that
so shank wing has one
um so that's one point
on this board it's half a point one and
a half
you need to get to three two and a half
and three so and i think there's been a
result on the the bottom board that's
been a
win
this one is that
um
yeah
so this means that america are through
so it's been so let's have a look at the
as azerbaijan match
yeah
versus poland
america through to the semi-finals
and
exciting position going on here between
mamedov and
radslov
um
[Music]
wow
time getting very short
black has one extra pawn
in the position but that pawn now gone
looks
like the black king has become
the bigger target after all this
and being very exposed maybe even the
rook can now join in the attack coming
down to h8 the queen comes in first
yeah then then rick shade is threatened
and it looks
okay but perhaps i can make queen
oh i think you i think uh this is very
bad isn't it for this is bad isn't it
because i think you simply just
check keep looking and coming closer and
closer to the king
um
black is now trying to maybe get some
kind of perpetual with the queen coming
like this this is this is his last
chance
and white probably calculating if
queen's e8 is going to force the win
here okay he's gone this way
and
he can now even simply
what's his idea here
okay so now i can go queen
queen takes f4 right
yeah you can always take this pawn with
check can't be bad yeah it can't be bad
and then you have to get okay oh okay so
this is nice
and if black doesn't have a perpetual
which i don't think he does no he
doesn't queen takes rook yes
well he might have perpetual i mean you
got
night check so we're going to see soon
oh and then
and then knight takes eight
so i thought
you can go be one did you look
then you try to put your king somewhere
safe king a
king a1
no no you have to queen suitcase it's
good it's good idea to repeat just to
gain some
then we come back
and now he has to get queen c4 check
remember if black doesn't have petrol
black is going to lose to rook h8 next
move
and
it's b3 b3 is easy winner actually if
you go queen c4 you don't play king a1
king b1 because the knight takes a3 and
all of a sudden this may be a draw
because a queen b free check yeah but
what you do play after queen c4 check is
you just play b3
and what about knight before after
knight b4 check
i think you can just take this one and
after this one you come forwards and
your king is going to escape the checks
by coming up the board yes black doesn't
have enough material here and so i think
this game's going to be over let's just
see if it ended that way and this is how
the game has actually gone king a1
maybe he's just gaining a little bit of
time on the clock
and now he's gone forwards king a4
and his king is going to go to b6
defended by the pawn no more church
yeah
[Music]
yeah now now there's nothing
so white won okay
easy so are we looking at an armageddon
now
okay so let's listen
so one to as by john there
now we're just going to go for the
boards so as by john our one
point up this one
the american match usa we know have gone
through
and still usa there
azerbaijan have won that once as by john
two points
and now azerbaijan
have won that one three points they just
need one more results yep so i i can see
from the test results i can see from the
results that um
azerbaijan have three and a half points
to poland's one and a half points with
one game outstanding which means that
azerbaijan have done it they have taken
the match to tie break to armageddon
yep so we're going to have an armageddon
to see who gets in the semi-final no
matter what the result of the last game
going on here
um the armageddon is really exciting
you've got to all stay tuned for that
it's the most it's actually it's you
know we only have to concentrate on one
game so we've got a better chance of
knowing what's going on as well
yeah all these games i'm like well
but it's brilliant i mean i just like
this you know you you that you have four
categories you have
male female
junior under 20 and female junior under
20 and one category gets picked and then
a player has to off that catch creek
gets uh has to step up and play this
armageddon game there's no increment the
player with the white pieces will get
five minutes on the clock
and the player the black pieces has four
minutes on the clock and gets draw odds
which means if the game ends in a draw
it will be the play of the black pieces
that wins the game
so oh it's this is going to be exciting
i would have felt a bit disappointed
simon if we'd gone through today without
an armageddon match i know armageddon's
great i mean we're just clarifying maybe
we can bring up the score
i don't even know what we call it but
just to show who's actually into the
semi-finals and who's being knocked out
we're trying to get that in the screen
shortly um to show you where we stand
but
we know america are now through to the
semi-finals and they are going to be
playing
who are they playing okay we can see
okay
oh america versus russia what a match
what a match tomorrow
what a match that's gonna be i can't
wait to see that one as well i mean
they're two of the most impressive
impressive teams they both went through
quite easily in the end russia and
america yeah
but we're gonna have a play-off and this
is where it's gonna get extremely
exciting between
azerbaijan and poland i just wanna just
clarify one thing about the armageddon
rules it's only one game the captains do
not pick who plays what actually happens
it's random
one of the boards is random so it could
be the top guys it could be the
juniors it could be any board and those
guys have to hold up the respect of
their whole nation
no pressure there nothing to worry about
no
assignment
it's it's yeah those categories are
chosen by random you know it's just a
drawing of lots and that's it it's uh
the beauty of it all can you imagine if
the penalty shootouts were done like
that
one person goes and has a penalty
shootout i mean no i mean you just have
these numbers and you just go okay
number ten person is number ten
i'll keep it
it would be insane
so we can we can now say that well this
armageddon's gonna happen we're gonna
take a short break something like five
to ten minutes don't make sure you don't
go too far you don't want to miss your
armageddon it's over
before you know there's no increment
there's another very exciting thing
about it and that's going to decide the
other semi-finalists
so we'll be back shortly five minutes or
so go get yourself a cup of coffee
quickly and we're going to see the
armageddon exciting stuff you thank you
yeah absolutely riveting
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
we are back with the final excitement of
the day
and it's a biggie it's a biggie it's to
decide who goes through to the
semi-final of the chess olympiad which
is the
rolls-royce of chess competitions
don't think i'd want a rolls royce i
prefer maybe a sports car or a motorbike
but you get what i mean
it's one game one armageddon game and
ivanka do you want to tell us which
board has been randomly picked yeah it
has been the category has been the
women's board
so
this means that the players are monica
sotko will be playing white for poland
against uh gunes
and the format is it's five the player
with the white pieces has five minutes
whereas the player with the black pieces
has four minutes but black has draw odds
and much more importantly there is no
increment
this is so important you think because
once you've been playing with increment
to adjust to a situation where you're
getting under one minute and not getting
any extra time most of the games we've
seen in armageddon over the last couple
of days have been decided by flagging
and that is part of the game you know
it's it's part of the process you know
if you move slow you're going to get
punished
this blitz chest
but the tension that these two players
have you rank here they're playing for
the place in the semi-finals and it's
all down to them is their team looking
their country looking or you guys in the
twitch chat as well seven thousand of
you seven thousand
seven thousand yeah
and many more elsewhere can you
can you imagine your country's
expectations are new so simon if you
were one of the coaches what would you
be telling your player
well i mean i i would try not to make
them too nervous i wouldn't be saying
you have to win i'd just be like okay
you enjoy the game you're a good player
you know what to do
if you lose you lose but just do what
you're capable of doing and get in there
and take them out so something like that
i don't know it's very hard you don't
want to make them too nervous it's going
to be a lot of nerves going on yeah um
you can't help but be nervous i mean i
know i'm going to say
monica soccer
is favorite only because she's so
experienced she's been in these playoff
positions before i've seen her like flag
people in in similar situations and i
just think that experience will calm the
nose but of course it's really random
really really random right whatever's
going to happen it's so hard
and the thing is though this is a very
very unusual play office like as you
mentioned before you know usually when
you're done playoffs it's been for
yourself you've you've just advanced you
know to the next stage of a knockout
championship that's fine and if you lose
you lose you just go home the next day
in a plane
here it's your country it's your whole
team
that's suddenly getting knocked out of
the competition
this is a little bit different perhaps
it's a bit stressful because i mean okay
you're either hero or you're a villain i
mean there's no two ways about it i know
if you lose no one's gonna well they
shouldn't be hard on you but you're
gonna still feel that yourself you're
gonna feel it and you can see them now
getting on the camera and well i i mean
the the tension is building we have to
remind everyone the format white has
three minutes black has four minutes but
black has the draw odds so if gune with
the black pieces manages to draw the
whole of the azerbaijani team go through
to the semi-finals i mean it's probably
really nerve-wracking for the teammates
you know if you're rajabov you know or
whoever it's not in your hands you're
like right i've just got to watch them
wait i think that's what you do you just
walk away you do want to
crack open a beer and pray
i remember when i was playing for
england in the uh in the over the board
and one of our captains really couldn't
handle it when we were in time pressure
he just walked away
yeah
so it's
it's five minutes versus four i don't
know i i just don't really you know
retail the time limit and white has the
five minutes and you can see them on the
camera i mean you know it's hard to tell
what they're going through but
you're going to be a bit twitchy and you
can see that gune is a lot younger i
don't feel more nervous experience
should bring you a bit of confidence but
it doesn't always work that way it
doesn't i mean would you like to be the
person that's picked to play ivanka yes
or no you know it's a tricky one do you
want to have a chance of being the hero
or do you want to just watch
i i'd i'd
rather just watch but i guess if if if
the women's category were picked and you
know they said hey you've got to do it
then i guess i would take a few deep
breaths and go okay fine i can i can do
this i've got this i'm excited i find
it's very useful actually to turn you
can actually turn nerves around because
by just by telling yourself that you're
excited because uh
it's interesting if you're excited and
if you're anxious and afraid it's the
same physiological reaction your heart
rate still increases so you can actually
trick your body and go okay i'm if you
tell yourself i'm excited so that's what
i would be doing in this situation
um i can see that the um the players are
tense
yeah yeah of course they're tense
there's no two ways about it i mean no
matter how cool you think you are it's
much it's much more tense when you're
playing in a team event because yeah if
you let yourself down okay you can get
over it when you when you you've got
that extra guilt uh no matter if it's
not your fault or not that you're
letting up not just your team your
nation down not i hope they're not
listening to me you know this is not
going to help i i think we're safe to
say that they're not listening there
they just have their
zoom call
and uh
so who does everyone think the game's
going to spark very shortly by the way
people who do you think
in the chats gonna take this one down is
it gonna be azerbaijan to play in the
next round or is it gonna be poland
remember it's the semi-finals tomorrow
against india and your net you're
getting that bit closer to the final
who's going to do it who is going to do
it
what about you who do you think is going
to do it ivanka i'm going poland but
you know
i i've got i i'm i i'm not in any way
you know saying i want them to win i'm
just saying because of experience and
i'm impartial in this one uh they've
both done
some pretty well i agree with you i'm
completely impartial um
is a great player monica is a great
player but she's a lot more experienced
and uh
i think she's gonna have the experience
to calm herself down in such a position
um yeah so i'm gonna go for monaco as
well
you know i feel nervous now
oh yeah well this is the name of the
game you know this is the whole thing
you know as spectators is actually great
when we emotionally get involved in the
sit in the game as well we're in we're
in and they're going for a slav and
another thing i would like to mention of
course
is
it is
no increment no increment at all
so
you have to play play and play look at
the tension on their faces and this is
not one of the sharpest ways that white
can play against a slav white's going
for i would say a bit more of a
positional approach gaining the bishop
pair um
and white's going to rely on these guys
later on
[Music]
but simon we've seen a kind of change of
tactic because you know traditionally
white has gone all out for the win uh
we've seen from the previous two
armageddon matches that in fact white
has just gone for quiet positions in
which they're slightly better and they
just keep prodding and prodding and
prodding and prodding until
someone either cracks or
loses on time well actually
in the previous examples just simply
lost on time
that's it and the clock i i'm going to
say is again the clock has proven so far
in armageddon to be one of the most
decisive things
let's talk about the position then so
white
has offered the exchange of queens and
blacks decided to keep them on the board
pawn structure double pawns are they
going to be a strength for a weakness i
can see why even playing a typical
french defense move f3 to try and open
up the rook and to give this bishop some
life you need to get rid of this pawn
here i mean this would be the move uh i
think i'd be playing quite quickly every
open it up try to generate something
against the king
okay
i was a little bit surprised by um a5
because i was expecting black to
actually start developing with knight
bd7 perhaps threatening e5
or
but i was surprised by f4 because you
know when you put a pawn on f3 you have
the chance to take this one after queen
c2 but now you're closing the position
up you have the bishop should you be
closing a position up when you have the
bishop i'm not so sure queen to c3 still
in the balance very in a balanced time
situation
they haven't they're moving quick
they're both moving very quick uh three
minutes to four minutes so they've kept
the i really like c5 c5 i think it's a
great move but look at this here it
comes monica is having a go you've got
to go for it you've got she's kind of
choosing a different strategy she's
going all in for the attack she
certainly is but black has the pressure
black is holding her now very well so
far that could you know you have to
defend this one something like rook to
d1 but then maybe e5 and the knight
comes to d4
e5 d4 d5 and the knight slips in here
supported after rook d1 i think this is
gunnae's strategy at the moment i think
you have to go right to d1 because um
yeah i mean you can try taking on e6
yeah but then you can do this
and she has she's done that i think
you've got it
knight
this is this is a big
getting wild but black's pieces seem to
be good javanco don't they they're not
there lovely
queen takes f7 and this bishop is such a
bad piece it's really not a good piece
do you if you put it on g4 you even fail
tonight takes g4 rook takes queen so you
have to defend the bishop rook to e1
okay and you do have the idea of c c 45
and uh try to activate the bishop
by c4 square yeah good good point but
black seems to be nicely positioned at
the moment okay and this pawn
the knights come in okay okay still
anything possible you've anchors me here
anything at all can happen
uh in this in this structure
good move i like that one get trying to
get rid of the strong light there yeah
i'll i like it too
um
they have some very interesting
situations here with uh both set of
rooks two set of rooks opposite uh
they're counterposing the queens so okay
so now is there
okay so she's threatening queen to g for
i think i think she wants to for example
just get the queen can i simply take the
pawn
um take this one
here well yeah maybe why not why not
take the pawn you probably have to try
something i mean you'd love to maybe
sacrifice but not here because there's
always a queen d4 queen to c4 check yeah
yeah and she has taken paul but that
wasn't
this is very risky because you've
allowed the queen in without having the
opportunity of exchanging it off
still in the balance black has the
initiative at the moment
time situation
i like black's position
you know rook to d2 is coming
yeah and there's a nice coordination
it seems more dangerous for white and
also i'm just not liking this bishop
this bishop is clumsy he's getting in
the way the knight here is a good
defender it blocks up lines queen b4
going for an ending probably a wise
choice because black's counterplay was
looking extremely strong in the position
rook comes in anyway yeah
and maybe you have to play queen takes
queen and rook b5 and go and try to win
some ending not easy to do
no
black fragra at the moment a really good
play from gunes she's holding a nerve
wait one second is there rook takes
regret quit this
rick takes quintes yeah and then rook to
b5 i like that move i think rook b5 but
okay the bishops come back i'm trying to
keep a bit of tension maybe going for
the e pawn at some moment uh getting out
of the way of the position time
situation do keep an eye on it there's
no increment let's remember
good move the rook's trying to come down
good high quality game so far rugby f5
has been played
okay well now now we can uh
and now bishop to
now i think bishop will come to g2 the
thing is if you play bishop g2 it's so
it's going to be so simplified you're
going to swap off yeah i'm pretending
just to make moves and flag you
yeah yeah you have to do something i
mean this is looking like it should be
an oh at least okay for black
black
keeping the call but i think this is the
right suit i think white has to risk it
hoping for rugby free bishop c4c or rook
a2 yeah
let's not play for that
let's not mention that
black now getting short time your banker
is the clock once you go under one
minute you start to freak out oh okay
well this allows this check now when my
bishop comes to life
um
a little bit not so much i'm just
thinking also there's a yeah i like
rookie one
okay
more exchanges
more exchanges occurring yeah but i feel
that this exchange helps me because i
can go rook takes e3 and then i can go
rook b3
yeah and then i'm going to go
at the right time
okay i i was thinking at the right time
going bishop g2 and going on that long
diagonal
look at the time they're under a minute
very shortly they've got to pick up the
pace it doesn't matter on the position
really if you win on time you win you
can go into dirty flagging mode
and
black nicely centralizing
white i'm surprised hasn't gone rook b3
yet but this must be coming soon
it must be it must be i'm kind of
expecting some kind of king g3
good mood
rick is there some kind of rook
f3
okay
black is just trying to simplify black
47 seconds each
yeah
now maybe you put the bishop on b5
stabilize that piece and try to
move but okay
one thing that white can try to do is
get to the g7 pawn somehow
um oh no she's blunted
oh she just missed it knight d3 would
have won immediately won the game oh wow
okay well what a
shot
but i think black is still in control
because of the time and it's okay
there's not much material on the board
no okay so it's 28 seconds versus 36.
okay but now we've got rugby five
comments you've got to hurry up you've
got to hurry up here white has said play
quick 24 seconds
it's all on the clock i feel that okay
now the threat isn't that case you're
seeing it knight to d5 all the knights
are so crafty pieces okay so
um
king d4 96 check mate
yeah
that black is well in charge if black is
this it'll be amazing black is doing
everything
centralizing playing quickly the pawn is
now on free
only chance to do time though
it's all on the clock it is it's 11
seconds against 21 seconds it's perhaps
too much she needs to take quickly some
tricks there now she's got my c3 check
knight c3 would have been fantastic it
would have been great you know so
oh look at this but still nice e3 the
fret is checked mate she's missed it
she's missed it
he's going to be winning it's going to
be winning she can't get out of the
checkmates checkmate unbelievable turn
around
oh no oh my no
she's throwing it away
two seconds to go
all my words wow
at the response on the webcams that is
unbelievable
unbelievable trick
to win and to put poland through and oh
my words you've got to feel for grenade
moniker i mean can we just show some of
those positions it was so tense so tense
but the first one was
black
was doing brilliantly but it just lots
of black and there was one position
where black could have won
immediately here black played rook a2
knight d3 check winning the rook winning
the game going through okay
but
we can have a look at um you know this
this is amazing stuff but this this
knight d3 was the first one if we go
right to the end before we just have a
look at the brackets yeah um
white managed to get some tricks going
in and all black had to do was play
knight to c3 get rid of that get rid of
that piece and uh would have been she
was ahead on time everything was working
in her favor
she she went for a check this was the
way to play and this and you get rid of
that bishop you should better hold this
just move your king like this i mean
also when you compare the time it was
four seconds versus 12 seconds and then
it would have just been pre-moved so any
any pre-move
yeah anything just move your king
just do it
keep checking and she was up on time
that's heartbreaking
heartbreaking wow
wow
it's so painful yeah so painful i really
you know well spotted here to monica for
setting that uh
mean mean check mate with the bishop on
the rook and uh yeah two seconds left
yeah she won with two seconds i mean
this was a deadly idea so last roll of
the dice yeah in a desperate situation
you might as well have a punt and i
really feel for grenade because she
played brilliantly the whole about and
anyway
that's what happens let's have a look
now at the brackets ivanka because we
can see who is playing tomorrow
painful stuff that but that takes poland
through to the semi-final against india
russia versus usa
big match
so i don't really know what to say that
i mean what do you guys think of the
chat i mean poor grenade uh but
brilliantly done by monica
i mean
tense stuff
we are going to be back tomorrow
with the semi-final and um hopefully
we'll see you then keep an eye on social
media on chess.com twitter chess.com
facebook for the times we're going to
start tomorrow it hasn't been announced
yet um i'm going to leave your bank of
the last words in a second but thank you
all for tuning in you've been fantastic
in the twitch chat remember to come
tomorrow it's even going to be better
ivanka your last words oh it's been a
wonderful matchup on what an armageddon
match at the end goodness me i couldn't
have asked for anything much more
dramatic i hope you've all enjoyed the
show and please tune in keep an eye on
social media for the exact time please
tune in tomorrow and simon i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
so
you